QUORUM YET BUT THAT'S RIGHT I
HAVE TO STILL INDICATE OUR
PROCEDURES AND THEN WILL CHECK
NOT HOPEFULLY WILL HAVE QUORUM
THEN. GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
TO THE GOVERNMENT IN NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES. WE
HAVE MODIFIED OUR VARIOUS
RULES. THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF US
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND THAT WE
CAN STAY SAFE. WE ARE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
THE CAPITAL SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- ACTUALLY WE
WILL NOT HAVE ANYONE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY-
WE ALSO HAVE BUT WE DO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. SO
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
BECAUSE IT HELPS US ELIMINATE
THAT ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. AND
EACH TIME THAT YOU WHICH TO BE
RECOGNIZED PLEASE USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE BECAUSE I CAN
SEE THAT THAT ON THE SCREEN
AND- GOOD KNOWLEDGE YOU- AND
YOU WILL ALSO MEET YOURSELF
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R.
I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU'RE DONE.
NOW TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW WE ALSO WILL
USE OUR TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
TODAY. FOR THOSE WHO
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT BY THE
TELECONFERENCE THE TOLL FREE
NUMBER IN THE ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
WE WILL ALSO BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN. DANCE FOR YOUR
INFORMATION ALL AN OUNCE IT NOW
THE NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX.
TWO EIGHT THREE ONE. ENTER TO
GET THE DETAIL INSTRUCTION HOW
IT WORKS YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
SENATE AND OR THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND AS I
INDICATED TO OUR- REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS. WHENEVER YOU ARE
GOING TO- GIVE TESTIMONY TO US
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESSING CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IS CLOSER THAN SAY MATTERS
CUSTOMARY. ARE THERE CAN ALWAYS
BE SOME TECHNOLOGICAL
DIFFICULTIES AND PLEASE BE
PATIENT AND RESPECTFUL WHILE WE
WORK THOSE OUT. SO NOW I THINK
WE MAY BE ABLE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM A CONSULTANT COULD YOU
PLEASE- CALL THE ROLL THAT'S
THE WORD YES. AB THE HIT WE
NEED THE MIKE ON FOR OUR
CONSULTANT. BIGELOW SENATORS
SKINNER I'M HERE SKINNER HERE.
NIELSEN CARRBORO. CORTESE
CORTESE HERE DOLLY. THE RAZA.
PRESENT HERE EGGMAN. GROWTH.
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER HERE LEHRER
HERE WE'RE HERE MCGUIRE AIR
MCGUIRE HERE MELINDA'S. MAN IN
HERE NEWMAN. BUT TROUBLE HERE
THE TROUBLE HERE IN THEIR PLAN
HERE STERN WHY KATHY HERE I
CAN'T BE HERE. SIR WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. I'M SURE
WE WILL- AGAIN OUR FORMAL
HEARING WE ARE GOING TO BE HERE
THREE BILLS TODAY B SEVENTY
NINE THE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
WHICH INCLUDES THE WELFARE WILD
FIRE PREVENTION AND RESILIENCY
EARLY ACTION PLAN WILL ALSO
HERE AB EIGHTY FOUR WHICH IS-
COVERS THREE HIRING AND
RETENTION OF DISPLACED WORKERS
IN THE HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY.
AND A. B. TWO ONE THREE THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS CLEANUP
WHICH ALSO CONTAINS SOME OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO HELP
IMPLEMENTED COVERT NINETEEN
SUPPORTS IN OUR SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS. AB EIGHTY FOUR IS A
CONTINUATION OF BUDGET EARLY
ACTIONS TO ASSIST CALIFORNIA'S
ONGOING RESPONSE TO AND
RECOVERY FROM COVERT NINETEEN-
THE HOSPITALITY SECTOR WAS ONE
OF THE SECTORS HARDEST HIT IN
TERMS OF JOB LOSS BECAUSE MUCH
OF IT HAD TO BE CLOSED ENTIRELY
AS WE KNOW FOR EXAMPLE THE-
MUSIC MEANT. PARKS CONVENTION
CENTERS VARIOUS THINGS HAVE HAD
TO BE CLOSED IN THEIR ENTIRETY
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC. CAUSING SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND JOBS TO BE LOST IN
THAT SECTOR SINCE FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY THE HIGHEST OF
ANY SECTOR WITHIN- WHICH AGAIN
CALIFORNIA. AND SO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WITHIN THAT
SECTOR NATIONWIDE IS TWICE THE
NATIONAL. UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
WOMEN MAKE UP THE LARGEST
PERCENTAGE OF THAT WORK FOR SO
SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED
THE REPORTS THAT INDICATE THAT
MORE WOMEN EITHER WERE LAID OFF
OR LEFT THE WORKPLACE DURING
THIS PANDEMIC THAN MEN AND IN
DECEMBER ALONE. WOMEN MADE UP
ENTIRELY THE LAYOFFS FROM. SRO.
FIVE ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT
MANY ECONOMISTS HAVE IS THAT WE
HAVE 80% OF WOMEN WHO MAY NEVER
RETURN TO THE WORK FORCE AND WE
WATCH THE NUMBERS FROM THE
RECESSION WE- THERE WERE MANY
PEOPLE WHO LOST JOBS DURING THE
RECESSION WHO'VE HAD A
DIFFICULT TIME EVER RETURNING
ESPECIALLY WITH OF SALT- FULL
TIME WORK SINCE THAT TIME-
GOVERNOR NEWSOM MADE HIS
ANNOUNCEMENT TO FULLY REOPEN
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH YOU JUST MADE THAT
RECENTLY. AND OF COURSE THE
HOSPITALITY SECTOR IS INCLUDED
IN THAT. NOW AB SEVENTY NINE
THE BILL- THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR ADDRESSES ANOTHER
ONGOING STATE EMERGENCY IN THE
WILDFIRE EARLY ACTION PLAN. AS
WE KNOW WE'RE IN VERY SERIOUS
DROUGHT CONDITIONS WE HAVE HAD
EACH SUCCESSIVE YEAR HAS BEEN
THE WORST WILDFIRE YEAR IN THE
PAST. AND IN THE PAST FEW YEARS
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
ADDITIONAL FUNDING HAS BEEN
DEDICATED TO WILDFIRE
SUPPRESSION- MEANING OUTSIDE
GETTING NEW HELICOPTER STATED
YOUR TOTAL TECHNOLOGY LARGE AIR
TANKERS VARIOUS HIRING
ADDITIONAL FIREFIGHTERS. AND
WE'VE SPENT A GOOD AMOUNT OF
MONEY ON SUPPRESSION BUT WHAT
WE NEED TO INVEST IN IS OUR
PREVENTION AND RESILIENCY
EFFORTS. UNDER EACH DOLLAR
INVESTED IN WILDFIRE PREVENTION
WE SAVE SIXTY SEVEN DOLLARS IN
DAMAGES- THIS THE WILDFIRE BILL
IS HAS AN APPROPRIATION OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SIX MILLION AND IT
PROVIDES AN IMMEDIATE DOWN
PAYMENT TO HELP THE CREASE THE
SEVERITY OF WILDFIRES. WE WILL
TAKE OUR PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER
WE HEAR ALL THREE OF THE BILLS
SO WE'LL HAVE THE PRESENTATION
AND DISCUSSION ON EACH OF THE
BILLS. OF COURSE EACH BILL WILL
BE PRESENTED INDIVIDUALLY WE
CAN DISCUSS THEM INDIVIDUALLY
BUT THEN THE PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL COME AT THE END ON ALL OF.
SO LET ME SEE IF MY VICE CHAIRS
HERE NOT SEEING HIM HERE- WE
WILL BEGIN WITH THE
PRESENTATION ON THE FIRST BILL
WHICH IS AB SEVENTY NINE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE YOU
CAN AB FOR BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTATION ON AB SEVENTY
NINE. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING A
MAN ARMY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THIS BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
INCLUDES PROVISIONS FOR THE
WILDFIRE PACKAGE AGREED UPON BY
THE ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE. ENABLE IMPORTANT
FIRE MITIGATION PROJECTS AMONG
OTHER THINGS TO PICK CELEBRATED
IN THE CURRENT YEAR. THIS
PACKAGE COMES ON THE HEELS OF
THE DEVASTATING TWENTY TWENTY
FIRE SEASON. WHEN WILDFIRES
BURNED OVER FOUR MILLION ACRES
ACROSS THE STATE. MORE THAN A
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FIRE SEASONS COMBINED
AND SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN
THE MOST RECENT FIVE YEAR
AVERAGE OF ACRES BURNED.
CALIFORNIA NOW FACES A SIMILAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FIRE SEASON.
FROM JANUARY TO MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIRES
RESULTING IN. EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
ACRES BURNED. I FIGURE WAS FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE FIRESAND
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY SIX ACRES
IN THE SAME TIME PERIOD.
CALIFORNIA IS ALSO TRACKING
DROUGHT CONDITIONS ACROSS THE
STATE IN AS ADDED ADDITIONAL
EMERGENCY FUNDING RESOURCES TO
PREPARE. IT IS WHEN IT IS
WITHIN THIS CONTEXT OF
INCREASED AND MORE DANGEROUS
WILDFIRES THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSED A ONE BILLION DOLLAR
WILDFIRE AND FOREST RESILIENCE
PACKAGE WITH THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE MILLION EARLY
ACTION. CHIU EXCELLENT. AND
FORCED HEALTH PROJECTS. AFTER
COLLABORATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. NOW INCLUDES FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX MILLION
FOR A BROAD SET OF INVESTMENTS
THAT SUPPORT A STATEWIDE
STRATEGY FOCUSED ON FOREST
HEALTH AND FIRE PREVENTION.
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE CRITICAL
TO CHANGING THE STATE'S
APPROACH TO MANAGING WILDFIRE.
STATE INVESTMENT SUPPORT THREE
SIMULTANEOUS FRONTS OF WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE. ITALIANS WITHIN%
COMMUNITIES AROUND COMMUNITIES
ACROSS LANDSCAPES. THERE ARE
FOUR KEY INVESTMENT CATEGORIES.
ONE CREATING RESILIENT WHILE
LANCE THIS PACKAGE INCLUDESTWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE
MILLION BOOKS ALREADY PROJECTS
THAT WILL HELP CREATE MORE
RESILIENT WHILE IN STATEWIDE
MITIGATING CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES IN A CASCADING
CLIMATE CONSEQUENCES LIKE
DAMAGE TO WATERSHEDS MUDSLIDES
AND LOSS OF HABITAT. OUR
WILDFIRE FUEL BREAKS. PACKAGE
INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO FIND
STATE PROJECTS AND GRANTS TO
LOCAL ENTITIES FOR EMERGENCY
FUEL BREAKS TO PROTECTION
UNITIES AND SENSITIVE AREAS
AGAINST THE IMPACTS OF
WILDFIRES. ISRAEL BREAKS ENABLE
FIREFIGHTERS TO TAKE A STAND
AGAINST A FIRE HE WAS DOUBLES
CONTAINMENT LINES INTO SECURE
EVACUATION ROUTES. THIRD WOULD
BE COMMUNITY AND HOME
GARDENING. ONE IN FOUR
CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN A HIGH
FIRE RISK STONE. DEFENSIBLE
SPACE AND RETROFITS TO HARDEN
HOME AGAINST EMBERS RESULT IN A
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER CHANCE OF
SURVIVAL IN THE WILD FIRE.
INVESTMENTS WITHIN COMMUNITIES
ARE ESSENTIAL TO PROTECT OUR
RESIDENTS FROM ALL TYPES OF
FIRES INCLUDING WIND DRIVEN
FIRES THAT SPREAD EMBERS AHEAD
OF THE FIRE FRONT. IT IS
PACKAGE INCLUDES TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT I
INTENDED TO LEVERAGE AN
ADDITIONAL SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
OF FEDERAL FUNDS TO SUPPORT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PILOT
PROJECT TO SUPPORT LOW INCOME
AND DISADVANTAGED HOMEOWNERS
NECESSITY IN ACCESSING RETROFIT
STAR IN THEIR HOMES. FOURTH
LAST WEEK IS CLIMATE RESILIENT
ECONOMIC GROWTH THE EARLY
ACTION PACKAGE INCLUDES
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS
WORKFORCE IN THE CLINTON
SHORTAGES. WHICH HAVE HINDERED
THE ACCELERATION EXHILARATING
PACE AND SCALE WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE. A THRIVING FORCED
IN WOOD PRODUCTS MARKET IN
CALIFORNIA WILL SUPPORT
SUSTAINABLE FOREST MANAGEMENT.
REGIONAL ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE. A THRIVING
MARKET IS ALSO CENTRAL TO
ASSURE THEIR OTHERWISE. ON
COMMERCIAL MATERIAL IS NOT LEFT
IN THE FOREST TO DECOMPOSE AND
RELEASE CARBON WILL BE PILE
BURNED. BY CREATING AN ECONOMIC
USE OF THESE PRODUCTS THE STATE
WILL GENERATE STRONG SUSTAIN
PRIVATE INVESTMENT AND FORCED
HEALTH. THE PACKAGE PROVIDES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
HELP STIMULATE THE FOR SECTOR
INVESTMENT IN ECONOMIC GROWTH.
INCLUDING AN INITIAL SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR TRANSFER TO THE
CLIMBING CATALYST FUND.
COMMERCIAL BANKS TYPICALLY
OFFER HIGH INTEREST LOANS IN
THE FOREST SECTOR IN RURAL
BANKS WHICH IS HISTORICALLY
FUNDED THE SECTOR HAVE CLOSED.
THE RESULT IS A SHORTAGE OF
CAPITAL EQUIPMENT AND BUSINESS
AVAILABLE TO HIGHER VEGETATION
TIRE FOR VEGETATION THINNING OR
FIRE RESILIENCE WORK. CREATING
LOW INTEREST LOANS WILL REMOVE
A MAJOR MARKET BARRIER AND
EXPAND CRITICAL BUSINESSES IN
THE SECTOR. IN ADDITION SIX
MILLION DOLLARS ARE AVAILABLE
FOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
GRANTS TO HELP COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAMS PROFESSIONAL
CERTIFICATIONS AND TRAINING. IN
ADDITION TO THESE WILDFIRE-
ACTIONS THE BUDGET DEAL JUNIOR
ALSO INCLUDES THREE POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE TO FIND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN A MICRO GRANT
PROGRAM FOR SMALL MID SIZED. IN
CALIFORNIA IT ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT TO
CARRY OVER UNSPENT CAP AND
TRADE FUNDS IN THE AMOUNT OF
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT THIS IS CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE NEEDED TO ACCESS THESE
FUNDS. BUDGET BILL JUNIOR ALSO
ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO ISSUE ONE TIME.
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR
PER CHILD STIPENDS TO THE CHILD
CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM PROVIDERS
WITH ORDER. TYPE WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE CURRENTYEAR
CHILD CARE STIPEND PAYMENTS
PASSED IN EARLY ACTION. IT ALSO
INCREASES THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES GENERAL FND LOAN OF
THIRTY FOR THE IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM
FROM FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
TO ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS NOT BEING ABLE TO MEET
PAYROLL NEEDS. TO THE TIMING OF
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS AT THE
END OF THE FISCAL YEAR. THE
BUDGET BUILDING ALSO PROVIDES
FORTY POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR
CHILDCARE FOR WELFARE SERVICES.
THESE ARE FOR KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC SUPPORT FOR FOSTER
YOUTH IN THEIR CARE GIVERS.
FINALLY THIS BILL ALSO INCLUDES
VARIOUS TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO
TREAT TWELVE EDUCATION ITEMS
THE REFLECT CHANGES IN THE
CURRENT YEAR FEDERAL AWARD
AMOUNTS IN CLEAN UP TO PROVIDE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION WITH YOU
FORTY NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
THAT IS BY THE END OF MY
PRESENTATION AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
LET ME SEE IF I'VE GOT MEMBERS
WITH QUESTIONS. SEN EARLIER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I HAD-
ONE QUESTION AND I ASKED THIS
QUESTION DURING THE BUDGET
HEARING- IN JANUARY IN RELATION
TO. ALTHOUGH OF FIRE ACTIONS
HOW MUCH OF WHAT'S IN THIS
PACKAGE WILL LOCALS BE ELIGIBLE
FOR AND HOW MUCH IS JUST BEING
DONE BY STATE AGENCY THE ANSWER
THAT CAME FROM FINANCE A FEW
WEEKS AFTER THAT INITIAL
HEARING. WAS SIXTY LOCAL FORTY
STATE AND I WONDERED IS THAT A
PERCENTAGE THAT'S HOLDING IN
THIS PACKAGE OR DID IT CHANGE
DO YOU KNOW WHERE IT TOUGH OF
FALLS. THANK YOU SENATOR- WE
DID KIND OF A- OUR OUR INITIAL
ASSESSMENT IS ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION IS GOING
TO BE GOING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BUT IF- IF WE MAY
WOULD LIKE TO- DOUBLE CHECK-
AND- GET BACK TO YOU BUT THAT'S
KIND OF OUR- INITIAL. ANSWER
THAT. SENATOR WHITE OAK GO
AHEAD CENTER LAYERED. OOPS
SORRY MAYBE A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION BECAUSE I HAD A
PERCENTAGE THE NEW AT A DOLLAR
NUMBER IF IT'S FOREIGN SIXTY
MILLION IS THAT EIGHTY TWENTY
AS OPPOSED TO SIXTY FORTY
WHERE'S THAT FALL PERCENTAGE
WISE BETWEEN LOCALS AND STATE-
I'M GONNA HAVE TO ASK. MY
COLLEAGUE- REBEKAH MORE OR JUST
MORE STE- I HELP HIM SIR AND
IT- WE MAY NEED TO GET BACK TO
YOU ON- MORE SPECIFICS ON THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M JUST GOT
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR FOREST HE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY AND- THIS PROGRAM IS
REALLY HEAVY ON A GREAT DOLLARS
GETTING OUT TO COMMUNITY SO FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE YOU CAN SEE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FORCE HEALTH GRANTS- JUST IN
EARLY ACTION ALONE WILL BE
ACCESSIBLE TO COMMUNITIES. V.
TEN MILLION IN THE FOREST
CALIFORNIA FORCED IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM FOR SMALL LANDOWNERS
WILL BE AVAILABLE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL- THE URBAN FORESTRY
PROGRAM WILL GO DOWN TO LOCAL
AND COMMUNITIES V. MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS THROUGH THE
CONSERVANCY'S WE'LL GET OUT TO
THE COMMUNITIES IN THEIR
REGIONS. AND FUNDING FOR THE
FIRE PREVENTION GRANTS A
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE MILLION IT
WILL ALSO GO OUT TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES- AND THEN GROUNDING
ALL OF THAT IS THE REGIONAL
PORTION FIRE CAPACITY PROGRAMS-
WHICH IS FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO REALLY EXPAND THIS
PROGRAM THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSERVATION THAT BUILDS
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENTS- AND- AND
CAPACITY. TO ACTUALLY STEER A
LOT OF THESE GRANTS INTO
REGIONAL STRATEGIES BECAUSE SO
MUCH OF OUR BDGET HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN FUNDED
THROUGH GRANTS OUT TO
COMMUNITIES WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT NEEDS ARE DONE IN A WAY
THAT IS STRATEGIC AND HAS A
CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF RESILIENCE
ON THE LANDSCAPING AND FOR
THOSE COMMUNITIES. SO THIS
REGIONAL PORTION FIRE CAPACITY
PROGRAM HAS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN HELPING REGION'S
DESIGNED- LANDSCAPE SCALE
STRATEGIES BUILD UP LOCAL
COLLABORATIVES THAT INCLUDE THE
VOICES OF ALL LANDOWNERS AND
THEN THE FUND THOSE PROGRAMS
THROUGH THE VARIOUS GRANTS THAT
I JUST LISTED- FROM STATE
ENTITIES AND SO WHAT WE'RE
SEEING NOW IS THIS FIFTY
MILLION. WILL ALLOW. RIGHT TO
EXPAND STATE AND TO NEW READ.
SUCH AS OR COUNTY THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO LIKE LOOK YELLOW.
AND AND NOW PERSONAL MY REACH
AND TO BE A TO DELIVER THOSE
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE- ON THE
GROUND AND DIRECT THE GRANT
DOLLARS- THAT WE HAD IN SHE
COMMUNITY COLLABORATIVES. DID
THIS REALLY PUTS COMMUNITIES
IN- YOU KNOW IN IN STEERING
THEIR OWN WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
BUT GIVING THEM EFFECTIVE TOOLS
TO O IT IN A WAY THAT IS GOING
TO BE STRATEGIC. IMPACTFUL AND
LONG LASTING. MADAM CHAIR. YES
GO AHEAD CENTER IT JUST A BRIEF
FOLLOW UP AND THAT IS I'M SURE
WHEN YOU SAID NAP AND CINNAMON
THE OTHER COUNTIES YOU MEANT TO
ADD SANTA CRUZ SO I'M GOING TO.
I'M GOING TO TAKE THAT BUT THE
OTHER THING IS AFTER THE
HEARING WE GET US MAYBE WHAT
YOU THINK YOUR BALLPARK IS A
PERCENTAGE OF STATE AND LOCAL
AND THEN WE'LL GO FROM THERE
THANK YOU TOOK- ALL RIGHT I.
HAVE I'VE SEE SOME OTHER FOLKS
WITH THEIR- MIKE STEP SO MANY
CALL AND SENATOR DOLLY SENATOR
MEN AND THEN SENATOR NELSON
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR I JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP
ON. THE LAST- SENATORS COMMENTS
SO WE THIS IS EARLY ACTION. AND
SO. IT'S URGENT WE ALSO WE OFF
OBVIOUSLY KNOW THERE'S WERE
SEEN DROUGHT WIND SO. I GUESS
FOR. MAYBE A LITTLE MORE
CLARIFICATION ON WE HAVE SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS WE HAVE.
FIRESTICK COUNCILS THIS YEAR
ABOUT A CONSERVANCY HAS A
BACKLOG IN MY DISTRICT OF
PROJECTS THAT NEED FUNDING. SO
WE WANNA GET THIS ON THE GROUND
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND MAKE
AND TRY TO GET AHEAD OF THIS
FIRE SEASON IS EXACTLY WHY
WE'RE DOING THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND I AND I COMMEND
THE ADMINISTRATION AND ALL OF
THAT LEGISLATORS FOR DOING
THIS. BUT WHO IS GOING TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR LIKE GETTING IT
TO THE GROUND THAT'S THAT'S I
THINK WHAT I THINK IS VERY KEY
IN SO WHO WHICH WHICH AGENCY IS
GONNA THEY GONNA JUST DIRECT
THE MONEY OUT ANOTHER TWENTY
MILLION IN THERE FOR ABOUT A
CONSERVANCY BUT- HOW'S IT GONNA
GO TO THE COUNTY SO THAT WE CAN
WATCH THIS IN THE NEXT. YOU
KNOW FEW WEEKS AFTER THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION GETS SIGNED AND
WE CAN ACTUALLY SEE THOSE
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS GET.
STARTED THANK YOU SENATOR I'M
GONNA TURN THAT QUESTION OVER
TO JESSICA MORSE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ABSOLUTELY THIS IS
INCREDIBLY URGENT AND- EVERY
WEEK WE CAN DO WORK OUT OF FIRE
SEASON- MAKES THIS FIRE SEASON
JUST A LITTLE BIT EASIER- AND
WE'RE ALSO SOBRE ABOUT THE
RESULTS WE CAN DELIVER ON
BECAUSE FIRE SEASON IS UPON US
NOW- SO IN HERE YOU HAVE.
PROGRAMS THAT ARE GONNA BE
DIRECTLY DONE BY THE STATE WE
HAVE REQUESTED CONTRACTING
RELIEF TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
GET PROGRAMS ON THE GROUND-
WITHIN JUST A FEW WEEKS WHERE
IS USUALLY A CONTRACTING
PROCESS WOULD TAKE- MONTHS AT A
TIME AND SO THIS ALLOWS US TO
GO QUICKLY. SO CAL FIRE IS
EXPANDING AND HAND CREWS AND
FUEL CREWS SO YOU SEE THIS
PROJECT START VERY QUICKLY
DEPLOYING NATIONAL GUARD-
CONSERVATION CORPS AND
EXPANDING FUEL CREWS ON THE
GROUND TO DO THESE STRATEGIC
FUEL BREAKS IMMEDIATELY WILL
ALSO BE SEEN THE CALVARY UNIT
FIRE PROJECTS. EXPANDING THOSE
ARE PART OF THE UNIT FIRE
PLANTS AGAIN THOSE WILL BE ON
THE GROUND VERY QUICKLY AND THE
FUNDING FOR STATE PARKS
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL I LIFE AND
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION ALSO
HAVE CONTRACTING RELIEF AND SO
WE'LL BE ABLE TO GET THOSE
DOLLARS- TO. THE GROUND SHOULD
PROJECTS- WITH IN JUST A FEW
WEEKS THE REST OF THE PROGRAM
IS- IN GRANT DOLLARS AND WE
ACTUALLY IN AN UNPRECEDENTED
MOVE. GRANT SOLICITATIONS
BEFORE WE HAD THE FUNDING IN
HAND SO THAT WE COULD EXPEDITE
THIS PROCESS AS YOU KNOW- IT
BEAT THE GRANT. THAT MANY OF
LOCAL COUNTIES AND COMMUNITIES
RELY ON THOSE GRANTS TO BE
EFFECTIVE AND SO WE'RE SEEING
THOUGH IS. TO GET ON THE GROUND.
LEE GRANT SOLICITATION ARE
ALREADY OUT WHEN WE GET USED
RESOURCE WILL BE ABLE TO STAY
AWARD THOSE FOR- BUT YOU KNOW
THAT WHILE. CRISIS JUST FIT ME
IN THE BUDGET CRISIS THE BEST
TIME TO BE ABLE TO GET WORK ON
THE GROUND WHEN YOU TYPICALLY
HAVE WHETHER WINDOWS. IS
BETWEEN- JANUARY AND MAY AND SO
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT
WINDOW WE'RE GOING TO START
GETTING WORK ON THE GROUND NOW.
BUT WE'RE HAVING AN
UNPRECEDENTED DRY SEASON WE'VE-
ALMOST DOUBLED THE ACREAGE
BURNED. AS THIS YEAR AS WE HAD
THIS TIME LAST YEAR SO WE ARE
IN A VERY SERIOUS SITUATION AND
THESE TOOLS WILL BE INCREDIBLY
IMPACTFUL- ND SO HERE THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY. WE ARE WORKING WITH ALL
OF THESE DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
GETTING THESE RESOURCES TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
DELIVERING. AN INCREDIBLY FAST
PACE BUT WE HAVE TO BE
REALISTIC THAT. THESE ARE MULTI
GENERATIONAL CRISES CUT
COLLIDING TO CREATE THE FIRE
CRISIS WE HAVE FROM. CHANGE AND
OF COURSE HOW. AND I SO YOU
CAN'T RULE IT BACK JUST IN TWO.
AND SO THIS IS. A FAST
INVESTMENT US A HEAD START AND
SHOULD BIAS RESULTS THAT WE CAN
SEE THIS FIRE SEASON. AND
CUMULATIVE RESULTS THAT WERE
REALLY START SEEING THE IMPACT-
BY NEXT FIRE SEASON. I THANK
YOU FOR THE THOSE COMMENTS I
APPRECIATE THAT- I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT WILL I KNOW
THAT I REPRESENT LEVIN COUNTIES
IT'S A HUGE AREA THAT HAS A LOT
OF OUR CD'S. HAS PARTED CANCELS
HAS THE CEREMONY CONSERVANCY-
AND THEY'RE ALREADY READY TO GO
I MEAN THEY JUST NEED FUNDING
AND SO THAT WAS AND SO I HEARD
A CCC I HEARD KALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW IN IN THEIR PROCESSES AND
THAT'S WHAT. ONE OF MY
FRUSTRATIONS HAS BEEN THAT WE-
IT MONEY IN THE PROGRAM AND WE
CREATE NEW PROGRAMS WHEN
THERE'S PROGRAMS THAT ARE UNDER
FUNDED RIGHT NOW THAT ALREADY
DO THE WORK AND THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT I JUST WANNA BE ABLE TO
TRACK IT BECAUSE I'M GONNA BE
WATCHING THIS. OVER THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS I AGREE WITH YOU WE
ARE WAY BEHIND THE CURVE. THIS
IS A DROP IN THE BUCKET BUT
IT'S ACTUALLY WE'RE DOING
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
POSITIVE FOR CALIFORNIA AND-
THE EARLIER WE GET ON THE
GROUND. THE BETTER TO WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO IT IN BEFORE
WE GET INTO FIRE SEASON WHERE
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DO THESE
PROJECTS WHEN IT'S HOT DROUGHT
TO BECAUSE ACTUALLY DOING THE
PROJECT CAN. CAN CREATE FIRE.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT I'LL BE
WATCHING AS WE GO THROUGH AND-
MAKING SURE THAT WILL HOPEFULLY
WE GET TO THE AGENCIES THAT ARE
ALREADY READY TO DO IT. THE R.
C. D. SIX FIRE SAFE COUNCILS
THE CONSERVANCY'S. SO WE CAN
GET ON THE GROUND. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY LET ME
GO TO SENATOR MEN NOW. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THE
EMPHASIS ON HARDENING AND
PREVENTION AND I'M AS A SOMEONE
WHO REPRESENTS ORANGE COUNTY
I'M I'M GRATEFUL YOU MENTION MY
AREA AND AS WE'VE SUFFERED- HI
TWO RECENT FIRES WITH BOND AND
SILVERADO WITHIN ONE MONTH OF
EACH OTHER- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
LOCALIZED NATURE FIRE RISKS-
BUT I WANTED TO. ASK YOU ABOUT-
MY BUDGET REQUESTS FOR A LITTLE
WHILE FIRE- AD PHASE TWO
EXPANSION I UNDERSTAND THE
ALERT WILDFIRE PHASE ONE WAS
SEEN AS TREMENDOUS SUCCESS
SUCCESSFUL- THE INSTALLATION OF
HUNDREDS OF CAMERAS IN. FIRE
PRONE AREAS ACROSS THE STATE
HAS PROVIDED FIRST RESPONDERS
WITH- YOU KNOW EARLY NOTICE OF
WHEN FIRES ARE OCCURRING- AND
THAT'S I THINK SAVED A LOT OF
LIVES SAVED A LOT OF PROPERTY-
BUT FACE TO AS I UNDERSTAND IT
WOULD WOULD PROVIDE DIGITAL
MAPS. THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHERE THERE
ARE FIRE RISKS WHERE FIRES
MIGHT HEAD- WHERE WE MIGHT
FOCUS OUR FUEL REDUCTION
EFFORTS AND ALSO ALLOWING FIRST
RESPONDERS TO TRY TO. FIGURE
OUT WHERE TO DEPLOY THEIR
RESOURCES WHEN FIRES ARE RAGING
ALL OF THIS I UNDERSTAND WILL
SAVE LIVES AND- THE COST OF
THIS PROGRAM AT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS- I REALIZE
EVERY BUDGET LINE ITEM IS
DEALING WITH SCARCE RESOURCES
BUT THIS SEEMS LIKE- SOMETHING
THAT IS A NO BRAINER JUST
BECAUSE OF THE POTENTIAL IT HAS
FOR ALLOWING US TO MITIGATE.
FIRE SO- I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
IT WOULD YOU CONSIDER THAT IN
IN AS WE GO FORWARD I HOPE THIS
COMMITTEE DOES CONSIDER
INCORPORATING THAT PROGRAM AND.
FUNDING IT IS IT'S PART OF OUR
DISCUSSIONS- THANK YOU SENATOR
I GUESS WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
THAT THE SCOPE OF THIS EARLY
ACTION PACKAGE BEFORE YOU IT IS
TO. IS REALLY FOCUSED ON THE
FIRE. BUT IN GETTING THESE
PROJECTS STARTED AS AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE. THERE IS OBVIOUSLY
ARE A NORMAL BUDGET CYCLE- NAY
NO BUDGET CYCLE- WHERE- WE HAVE
THE MAIN REVISION PROCESS THAT
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF- A
DEVELOPING IN THERE WILL BE
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
TWENTY TWENTY. ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET. AND THAT THERE WILL BE.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON ADDITIONAL ITEMS
AT THAT TIME. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU SENATOR MEN
SENATOR NIELSEN. BUT DO YOU
HAVE A CLARIFICATION OF FINANCE
IF I MAY. IN THE MY- COLLEAGUE
FROM THE COAST AND FROM BEAVER-
WE'RE ASKING ABOUT THE DIRECTED
MONIES TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT I
WANT TO BE IS IT SPECIFICALLY
CORRECT THAT THESE MONIES WOULD
BE DIRECTED TO IN PART. FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS AND RESURS RESURS
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
WILL THEY BE ACCESSIBLE TO
THOSE ENTITIES. I'D LIKE TO
TURN THE QUESTION OVER JUST
COMMERCE. THE QUESTION SENATOR
YES V. V. PROGRAM- THE REGIONAL
FORTUNE FIRE CAPACITY PROGRAM
AT THE RESOURCE CONSERVATION AT
THE END DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION PARTNERS DIRECTLY
WITH COUNTIES AND RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AND SO
ONE OF THE MAIN TOOLS WE HAVE
FOR GETTING THEM RESOURCES IS
ENSURING THAT WE'RE GIVING THEM
THE CAPACITY IN THE TOOLS TO
SUCCEED. AND THEN OUR GRANT
DOLLARS FROM THE FOREST HEALTH
PROGRAMS FIRE PREVENTION GRANT
THEN HERE IN DIRECTLY TO THOSE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO APPLY
FOR THE GRANTS BUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS ENSURING THAT THEY ARE
GETTING THE TOOLS TO SUCCEED-
AND SO B. THE PROGRAM PART OF
THE INNOVATION HERE IS THAT. WE
ARE EXPANDING THE EXISTING OUR-
REGIONAL FORCING FIRE CAPACITY
PROGRAM WHICH DOES INCLUDE
SANTA CRUZ ALREADY AND-
EXPANDING IT YOU KNOW COVER
STATEWIDE SO WITH THAT BEING
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
AND LOCAL COUNTIES HAVE DIRECT
PATHS TO GET FUNDING- IN
ADDITION TO THE- THAT HELP
SUPPORT AND EXPEDITE OUR GRANT
DOLLARS- AND THIS ALSO GETS
DOLLY WAS RAISING ABOUT SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS THE MAJORITY OF
THE FUNDS IN HERE ARE DIRECTED
EXACTLY TOWARD SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS. THAT THAT IS OUR
CLEAR CRITERIA THAT YOU'RE
NEVADA CONSERVANCY HAS A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
SHOVEL OVERA HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE SHOVEL READY PROJECTS
WHICH IS WHY THEY ARE GETTING-
DIRECT FUNDING AND SO I JUST
WANT TO BE REALLY CLEAR THAT
FOR THE EARLY ACTION DOLLARS IT
IS GOING TOWARDS SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS AND I'M JUST TRYING TO
EMPHASIZE THAT WE HAVE PROVIDED
TOOLS TO ALSO THEN. SUPPORT
REGIONS IN ACCESSING THOSE
DOLLARS. MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY. THE ANSWERS
QUESTION IN REGARD THE R. C.
D.'S BUT ABOUT THE- FIRE
COUNCIL. WHAT THEY CALL AND
LOCAL. THE FIRE TO ALL OF THESE
GRANTS AVAILABLE TO ANY ENTITY
THE FIRE SAFE COUNCILS ARE
OFTEN RECIPIENT OF THE FIRE
PREVENTION- GRANT FUNDING OF
WHICH THERE'S A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE MILLION I BELIEVE
I'M IN THIS IN THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL- FOR. FIRE PREVENTION
GRANTS SO THEY ARE PART OF THE
TEAM ON THIS EFFORT AND- AND
ARE WE ARE GIVING THEM SUPPORT
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS THESE
DOLLARS QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY
LET ME FOLLOW UP AGAIN AND- MY
FIEND FROM BEAVERS QUESTION
TO- DO YOU HAVE A TRACKING
SYSTEM. IN PLACE. AS THE MONEY
THAT IS A LOT OF THIS YEAR WILL
THERE BE TRACKING TO SEE HOW
THIS WENT. WHAT THE SUCCESSES
BANNED. ANY ASSESSMENT OF THE
SUCCESS OF THE MONIES. DEALT
OUT TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
CERTAINLY ON THE AND WE ALREADY
HAVE TRACKING SYSTEMS FOR THESE
LARGE GRANT PROGRAMS SUCH AS
THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
MILLION IN FIRE PREVENTION
GRANTS THAT HELP US A REPORT
OUT ON WHAT THE DO YOU AND- AND
HOW THEY ARE DELIVERED THE
REGIONAL ALL OF THESE ENTITIES
ALREADY HAVE. MECHANISMS THAT
TRACK AND THEN WILL BE-
TRACKING IT INTERNALLY AS A
WHOLE PROGRAM AS WELL TO
DELIVER THE RESULTS BUT IT'LL
IT'LL LIKELY BE LOOKING AT.
WHEN YOU'RE REALLY LOOKING AT
HOW DO YOU MEASURE SUCCESS WILL
BE ABLE TO MEASURE THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE AND- THE
ACTIVITIES WE'VE ACHIEVED AND
WHERE THEY ARE- BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S REALLY CRITICAL
SUCH AS WE LEARN THE LESSON
WITH LIKE THE THIRTY FIVE
EMERGENCY FUEL. SAVE LIVES FOR
EXAMPLE WE WENT DOWN TO THE
CREEK FIRE WHERE WE HAD FIVE
EMERGENCY FUEL BREAKSTHAT HAVE
BEEN PUT IN WITH THE NATIONAL
GUARD. IN TWENTY NINETEEN IN
RECORD TIME AND THEY SAVE LIVES
AND HOMES AND CREATIVE STATION
ACTIVATION ROUTES DURING THE
CREEK FIRE WHICH IS ONE OF THE
MOST DYNAMIC AND- DEVASTATING
FIRES WE HAD IN STATE HISTORY.
AND SO THESE RESILIENT%
ACTIVITIES- WE'RE GONNA BE
TRACKING OUR WORK AND OUR
PROGRESS BUT- WE'LL SEE ADDS
FIRE RESILIENCE MOVES FORWARD
HOW WE'RE ACTUALLY- LESSENING
PROPERTY DAMAGE. I'M KEEPING
CALIFORNIA SAFE AND ENSURING
THAT OUR ECOLOGIES ARE HEALTHY
AND FIRES RETURNING BACK TO ITS
NORMAL ECOLOGICAL NORMS AS
OPPOSED TO THESE CATASTROPHIC
FIRES WERE EXPERIENCING. AND
HELL WOULD LEGISLATE TORS OR
INDIVIDUAL CITIZENS ACCESS THAT
DATA THAT INFORMATION THAT
TRACKING. INFORMATION HOW WOULD
WE- THAT WE HAVE- LET'S JUST
REPORTS THAT COME OUT. ALL OUR
FIRE PREVENTION AND- FOREST
HEALTH GRANT PROGRAMS AND SO
WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE. OUR LEGISLATIVE
REPORTS- ALONG WITH THESE
PROGRAMS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON RECEIVED THERE'S
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR
MEMBERS- PROMISE EVEN. BURKE
SAID BOB SENATOR AKOWSKI NO YOU
DO NOT HAVE YOUR MAKEUP SO NO
OTHER FOLKS WITH MY- ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL SEEING NO OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE WE WILL GO
TO IF YOU RECALL I AND NOW IT'S
DOES WE OPEN THIS HEARING THAT
WE WILL TAKE OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AT THE END OF HAVING
THE PRESENTATION AND DISCUSSION
ON ALL THREE BILLS SO WE WILL
NOW MOVE. TO THE- NEXT- BILL.
WHICH IS- PLEASE NEVER GET TO
GO BACK TO MY LITTLE SCRIPT- AB
EIGHTY FOUR. SOUTH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE CAN YOU- BEGIN THE
PRESENTATION ON AB EIGHTY FOUR.
YES THANK YOU SENATOR- SO THE
COMPANY NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
HAD A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
ON LOW INCOME EMPLOYEES THIS
BILL ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS THE
NEGATIVE ECONOMIC IMPACT ON
EMPLOYEES IN THE HOSPITALITY
AND BUILDING SERVICES
INDUSTRIES WERE LAID OFF DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC. THIS BILL
PROVIDES A STATEWIDE UNIFORM
POLICY FOR THE RECALL OF LAID
OFF EMPLOYEES BY THEIR
EMPLOYERS AND IT TENDS TO
PROVIDE THOSE WORKERS WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REGAIN
EMPLOYMENT SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL REQUIRES SPECIFIED
HOSPITALITY EMPLOYERS TO OFFER
ANY NEWLY ESTABLISHED POSITIONS
TO QUALIFIED FORMER EMPLOYEES
LAID OFF FOR COLLUDED NINETEEN
RELATED REASONS WITHIN FIVE
BUSINESS DAYS OF ESTABLISHING
THE POSITION. THROUGH DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. I WAS ABLE IN PLEASE ARE
THOSE WHO WORK FOR THE EMPLOYER
FOR SIX MONTHS OR MORE DURING
THE TWENTY NINETEEN CALENDAR
YEAR IN WERE LAID OFF DUE TO A
PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTIVE
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN ORDER. LACK
OF BUSINESS OR ANOTHER.
ECONOMIC NON DISCIPLINARY
REASON BECAUSE BY THE COBIT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. BUSINESS IS
SUBJECT TO THIS OBLIGATION OUR
HOTELS AND PRIVATE CLUBS WITH
FIFTY OR MORE ROOMS. LARGE
EVENTS CENTERS WORDS REPORTER
HOSPITALITY AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND BUSINESSES THAT
PROVIDE DRAINAGE. FINANCE OR
SECURITY SERVICES TO COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS. THIS REQUIREMENT
APPLIES TO THE SPECIFIED
HOSPITALITY AND BUSINESS
SERVICES EMPLOYERS EVEN IF THE
EMPLOYER OR ALL OF THE ASSETS
OF THE EMPLOYER AFTER HE HAVE
CHANGED OWNERSHIP SINCE LAYING
OFF THE EMPLOYEE PROVIDED
THEY'RE STILL CONDUCTING THE
SAME OR SIMILAR BUSINESSES.
THIS BILL ALSO APPROPRIATES SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO FORCE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY AND. ANSWER
QUESTIONS OKAY- LET'S SEE IF
THERE ARE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS%
FROM MEMBERS CENTER NIELSEN.
THE MANAGER OF THIS AND I'M
OBJECTING JUST FOR THE RECORD
THIS IS A MAJOR POLICY BILL
BEING. PUT IN THE GUYS AND I
USE THAT WORD VERY EXPLICITLY
GUYS. OF A BUDGET BILL THE
TRAILER BILL I DON'T THINK IT
IS A TRAILER BILL I THINK IT IS
A POLICY BILL IT SHOULD GO TO
COLLEGE- COMMITTEE THERE ARE
MAJOR POLICY. DECISIONS HERE.
IN THIS LEGISLATION. AND PLEASE
DO ALSO AFFECT BUSINESS AND IN
A MAJOR WAY. THERE ARE
PROVISIONS IN HERE OF THE RETRO
ACTIVE. THE POSITIONS REGARDING
WHO COULD COME BACK TO WORK AND
UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES. AND
IT DOES I THINK AT LEAST
DISCOUNT OF NOT OBVIATE
CONSIDERING MARRIAGE AND THE
RECALL. OF WORKERS. A LOT OF
PROVISIONS IN HERE I THINK. DO
WARRANT THE IN DEPTH SCRUTINY
AND OUR HEARING HERE TODAY
CERTAINLY IS NOT SUFFICIENT FOR
THAT PURPOSE. AND NORA
COMMITTEE WHEN WE VOTE NOR IN
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE. STILL
I'M OBJECTING AND I THINK THAT
THERE ARE SOME PROVISIONS IN
HERE THAT I THINK- OUGHT NOT BE.
YOU SEE IF THERE'S THE OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS SENATOR
LAYERED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
BUT THOUGHT I BOUGHT HAD SOME
ANGST ABOUT. THIS BILL JUST ON
THE BASIS THAT I AM NOT.
CERTAIN THAT PEOPLE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL ARE FULLY AWARE OF.
THE FACT THAT THIS IS MOVING-
PARTICULARLY SINCE I KNOW AND-
IT AND NOW ONE OF MY DISTRICT
COUNTIES MONTEREY THERE'S A BIG
DEBATE- ABOUT THIS GOING ON AND
I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ANYONE IN
MONTEREY COUNTY AND SO THAT
GAVE ME CONCERNED. I THINK OUR
OUR I ALSO MET A DISADVANTAGE
IN THAT THIS WAS THOROUGHLY
DEBATED- BEFORE I WAS HERE. IN
THE SENATE. AND THE GOVERNOR
VETOED IT BUT HE LAID OUT
THINGS IN THIS BILL CLEARLY
ADDRESSES EACH OF THOSE AFTER
THAT THOROUGH DEBATE WHETHER IT
IS. A SUNSET THAT DIDN'T EXIST
WHETHER IT'S REALLY TIED
COVERED WHICH WAS DIFFERENT
THAN WHETHER IT REMOVES THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION SO
WHILE I WISH THIS WAS MOVING IN
A WAY. THAT I COULD HEAR FROM
LOCALS AND THEY WERE FULLY
AWARE OF IT- I THINK THAT THAT
GIVES ME ENOUGH OF A COMFORT
LEVEL TO MOVE IT ALONG. FIVE
SENATOR DOLLY I GOT YOU BUT LET
ME HAVE SENATOR DRAWS SO FIRST
THAT WAS THE NEXT DAY AND I SAW
IT UP. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I
JUST WANT TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE- ISSUES BEFORE US THIS WAS
A BILL THAT WAS FULLY DEBATED
THOROUGHLY DEBATED. LAST YEAR
WHEN WE WERE IN THE WORST PART
I THINK OF OUR OF OUR PANDEMIC
OF CONCERN ESPECIALLY FOR WOMEN
WORKERS. THIS INDUSTRY HAS A
OF- SIGNIFICANT IF NOT MAJORITY
WOMEN WORKERS WE KNOW TO STUDY
AFTER STUDY AFTER STUDY THAT
WOMEN WORKERS ESPECIALLY AS
THEY GET A LITTLE BIT OLDER ARE
THE MOST DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
WHEN IT COMES TO. THREE ARE
GETTING THEIR JOBS BACK- AND
THIS HAS BEEN SHOWN NATIONALLY
AS WELL AS IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE WOMEN
IN THIS INDUSTRY TO BE ABLE TO
GO BACK TO THE JOB THAT THEY
HELD THAT IT NOTHING MORE
NOTHING LESS JUST GET THEIR
JOBS BACK SO THIS WAS FULLY
DEBATED LAST YEAR IT WENT ALL
THE WAY. TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
AND THE GOVERNOR RAISED SEVERAL
ISSUES OF CONCERN TO HIM IN THE
VETO MESSAGE ALL OF THOSE
ISSUES HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED IN
THIS BILL ALL OF THOSE ISSUES
FROM- THE LINK THERE IS A
SUNSET IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
LAST YEAR THERE WAS NO. LAWS
SUNSET. SOME OF THE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION WELL THERE WERE
SEVERAL OTHER OF THE SCOPE THAT
IT HAD TO BE RELATED TO. A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY LIKE
COVERT NINETEEN. OF THEIR WORDS
NO- IT WAS NOT THAT NARAL LAST
YEAR IS VERY NARROW THIS YEAR.
AND REALLY GOES TO THE HEART OF
THE ISSUE IS. WORKING PEOPLE IN
THE VERY VERY CRITICAL INDUSTRY
TO CALIFORNIA. THOSE MEN AND
WOMEN ESPECIALLY WOMEN- NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN LOST THEIR
JOBS BECAUSE OF THIS PANDEMIC.
ALL IT'S SAYING IS LET'S ALLOW
THEM TO GO BACK TO THEIR JOBS
LET'S JUST MAKE SURE THEY GET
BACK TO WORK. NOW THE TIMING IS
SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE ARE
OPENING UP OPENING UP WILL
FULLY OPEN UP IN A MATTER OF
MAYBE A COUPLE OF MONTHS. AND
THOSE PEOPLE THOSE WORKERS
THOSE WORKING FAMILIES SHOULD
BE ABLE TO COUNT ON THEIR THEIR
JOBS SO THE URGENCY IS NOW TO
GET THEM ALLOW THEM TO GET BACK
TO WORK- AND I REALLY BELIEVE
THE- THE NARROW SCOPE. IS THAT
THE KEY ELEMENT HERE AND THAT
WE FULLY DEBATED THIS LAST YEAR
SO I REALLY URGE. EVERYONE TOOK
TO LOOK AT THAT AND SUPPORT
THIS OF FOR THE TIMELINESS FOR
THE FOR THE FACT THAT WE FULLY
DEBATED THE FACT THAT IT'S
IMPACTING SO MANY WOMEN WHO
JUST WANT TO GET BACK TO WORK.
THANK YOU MENTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALI FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
CAFIERO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I WANTED TO SHARE- A
LITTLE BIT EXPERIENCE AS A
BUSINESS OWNER ON JUST
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
HAPPENED DURING COVERT SO
NUMBER ONE FIRST WE DID A STATE
HOME ORDER EVERYBODY WENT HOME.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALONG
WITH THE STATE GOVERNMENT
ALLOWED. THERE ARE POLICE TO
YEAH WE GET TO UNEMPLOYMENT ONE
OF THE HUGE PROBLEMS WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT APARTMENT WE'VE
ALL DEALT WITH THAT NOT GONNA
GO THERE BUT IS THAT THEY
DIDN'T ASK THE EMPLOYERS. WHEN
THE EMPLOYEES WERE LAID OFF
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WAS LAID OFF
FOR A SHORT PERIOD FOR SURE AND
IN THIS THEY WERE SENT TO
WORKERS- BUT WHAT HAPPENED WAS
THAT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GAVE
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS A WEEK AND
THEN. AND THEN THE MAXIMUM I
THINK FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
CALIFORNIA'S. MAYBE FOUR
HUNDRED A LITTLE MORE. SO SOME
OF THESE EMPLOYEES ARE ACTUALLY
MAKING MORE MONEY BY NOT
WORKING. BECAUSE OF THE FEDERAL
INFUSION OF RESOURCES. TO CAUSE
A PROBLEM FOR THOSE BUSINESSES
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO HIRE THE
BACKS OF MANY. BUSINESSES WHICH
I KNOW PERSONALLY- FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES WOULDN'T COME BACK TO
WORK BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
ABILITY FOR THE E. D. TO
ACTUALLY DIDN'T SAY STOP
QUANTIFYING. TO THE TO THE
EMPLOYERS IF THEY WERE. REALLY
UNEMPLOYED BECAUSE IF YOU OFFER
THEM BACK THEIR JOB. AND THEY
DON'T AND THEY DON'T RETURN TO
THEIR JOB. THEN YOU ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO PAID EMPLOYMENT BUT
THE EMPLOYMENT DEPARTMENT
DIDN'T. FILL IN THAT LOOP SO A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT WERE WORKING
WERE WHY WOULD THEY GO BACK TO
WORK WHEN THEY'RE MAKING MORE
MONEY BY NOT WORKING BECAUSE OF
THE- RESOURCES THAT WERE PUT
IN. TO NOW THIS BILL WE COME WE
FAST FORWARD TO THIS TIME.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO IT WE'RE
GOING TO PENALIZE SOME OF THOSE
EMPLOYERS. BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
HIRE IN A DIFFERENT I WOULD
TELL YOU IF I OFFERED A JOB
BACK TO MY EMPLOYEE WHO DIDN'T
COME BACK BECAUSE THEY WERE
MAKING MORE MONEY BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND THE
STATE WAS PUT. PASSING OUT
MONEY AND WASN'T VERIFYING. THE
REASON FOR THEM TO LOSE THEIR
JOB. I WOULD NOT WANT TO HIRE
THEM FIRST BECAUSE THEY HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BACK TO
WORK. AND THEY DIDN'T COME BACK
TO WORK SO MY POINT IS THAT
IT'S UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
BUT IS NOT DEALT WITH. IN THIS
SCENARIO ED BUT IT PENALIZES.
THE BUSINESS OWNERS AND MANY OF
THESE ARE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
THAT ARE VERY STRUGGLING RIGHT
NOW. TRANSMITIDO USES ISSUE
IT'S NOT BEEN TALKED ABOUT BUT
IT'S A FACT. IN ITS IN ITS
REALLY DIFFICULT AS A BUSINESS
OWNER THEY HAVE THE LEGISLATURE
PUSH DOWN THESE RULES. WHEN
YOU'RE BASICALLY TELLING US HOW
TO RUN OUR BUSINESS WHEN
THERE'S- WE HAVE WE COULDN'T
GET THEM TO COME BACK TO WORK
IN THE FIRST PLACE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR CAREER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS BUT I
WANT TO START OUT BY SAYING- I
SUPPORT OF THE BILL LAST YEAR
AND I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL
THIS YEAR BUT THE KEY IS THAT
THAT IS MAKING SURE YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S IN THE BILL.
IT'S BEEN SAID TO ME THAT- PAGA
HAS BEEN- TAKEN OUT OF AND I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE- AT SO THE
FIRST QUESTION I HAVE IS- AND
THAT THERE IS NO PAGA-
PRESCRIPTION IN THE BILL NUMBER
ONE- NUMBER TWO CAN AN EMPLOYEE
BROUGHT BRING A PRIVATE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION THAT'S NUMBER
TWO AND I'M ASSUMING IF THE
ANSWER IS NO THERE'S NO PAGA IT
NO THERE'S NO PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION THAT IT'S A LABOR
COMMISSIONER THAT'S ENFORCING
THIS AND SO I WANNA MAKE SURE
OF THAT- AND THEN AND THEN.
LASTLY I I'D LIKE TO- THAT
CONFIRM THAT THIS OVERRIDES
LOCAL ORDINANCES- I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE WE'RE ALL WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S WHAT IT
WHAT IT'S DOING I BELIEVE
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL SAYS I
JUST WANT A CONFIRMATION OF
THAT ADAM CHAIR AND THEN I
JUST THINK THE WHOLE PURPOSE
FOR THIS OBVIOUSLY IS THAT- I
NOW THAT WHERE WE CAN MOVE
AROUND A LITTLE BIT I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO TRAVEL AND COMING BACK
AND FORTH FROM HOME TO
SACRAMENTO. THERE ARE HELP
WANTED SIGNS EVERYWHERE AND- I
THINK WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS WE
WANT TO GET PEOPLE BACK TO WORK
AS QUICKLY. AS POSSIBLE. NOT BE
SLAPPING- BUSINESSES. MAY
INADVERTENTLY. MESS UP AND SO
THAT THAT'S MY ONLY CONCERN IS
THAT- THIS IS KIND OF
PRESCRIPTIVE LIKE I SAID I'VE
SUPPORTED IT IN THE PAST
BECAUSE I REALLY DO THINK THAT
EMPLOYEES ARE TO BE HIRED BACK
BY THEIR EMPLOYERS- IF THEY
WERE DOING A GOOD ENOUGH JOB
BACK BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THEY
THEY NEED TO BE RE HIRED AGAIN-
BUT IF I COULD GET THOSE THOSE
QUESTIONS ANSWERED I APPRECIATE
THANK HURTLING. FAR IN FINANCE
CAN YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR- I'M
GONNA ASK ROBERT- THE LOBOS- TO
HELP ANSWER THAT QUESTION THANK
YOU. HERE ON MUTE. YOU NEED TO
ON ME YOURSELF DANCER. OKAY CAN
YOU HEAR ME NOW YES. OKAY YES
ROBERT THE LOCALS FROM THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
AND- YOU KNOW THE ANSWER TO
BOTH QUESTIONS I THINK IS NOT
ADDRESSED IN THE IN THE
LANGUAGE AND IN THE SECTION
ITSELF AND IT CONFERS EXCLUSIVE
JURISDICTION- UPON THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER. AND THAT THE
SECTION CAN ONLY BE ENFORCED.
BY A COMPLAINT THAT'S FILED BY.
EIGHTY LAID OFF EMPLOYEE A WITH
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
SO I GOT THAT DONE VERY-
EXPRESSING AND DEFINITE-
LANGUAGE. SPEAKS TO BOTH THE-
THE LACK OF A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION IN THE IN A FLEXIBILITY
TO. THANK YOU. SENATOR MAN JUST
TO BE SURE THAT- THE BILL- IT.
IS MANDATORY IN TERMS OF THE
ENTIRE STATE AND SUPERSEDES
LOCAL ORDINANCES. YES IT DID IT
WAS  DOCTOR LOCAL ORDINANCES-
BUT WOULD STILL BE ALLOWED TO
EXIST HOWEVER THEY COULD NOT
AFFORD ANY PROTECTION THAT
WOULD BE LESS THAN WHAT IS
PROVIDED UNDER STATE LAW SO
THERE IS THEIR DINNER. THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO EXIST ABOUT
WHAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO BE
ENFORCED IN A MANNER WHICH
WOULD BE DONE WITH THE-
FUNDAMENTAL REQUIREMENT
SUPPOSED LACK OF THE STATE.
LANGUAGE C. PROVISIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LET ME SEE VERY
SEE ANY OTHER. MIKE SAID- THE
COMMON I WANTED TO ADD IS THAT-
HI. I THINK IT IS CERTAINLY THE
INTERESTING THING WAS WE'VE
NOTED MORRIS- DESCRIBED IS THAT
THIS IS A SECTOR THAT HAD VERY
HUGE JOB LOSS WHICH OF COURSE
IT WOULD HAVE BECAUSE IT
CLOSED- AND INTERESTINGLY IT IS
ALSO RIGHT NOW THE SECTOR THAT
IS OPENING. MOST QUICKLY. AND
SO THERE THAT IS A THAT GIVES
US THAN A RATIONALE FOR WHY WE
WOULD WANT TO ACT NOW TO HELP
INSURE THAT THOSE EMPLOYEES WHO
AS ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUE STATED
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN LOSS OF
JOB. NOW HOWEVER. SOME OF THOSE
EMPLOYEES MAY CHOOSE NOT TO GO
BACK RIGHT NOW AND THAT IS
THEIR CHOICE NOW FOR SOME OF
THEM IT MAY NOT BE IN EFFECT
WHAT I WANT TO CALL A. THERE'S
CHOICE AND THEIR CHOICE BUT I
THINK WE- YES IT ON UNDER
EMPLOYMENT WITH THE ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROVIDED SOME LOADS
LOW WAGE WORKERS WERE
COMPENSATED DID HIGHER HOWEVER.
THE CHOICE TO GO BACK TO WORK
OR NOT LET'S TAKE FOR EXAMPLESOME OF THE WOMEN IN THE
SECTOR. IS ALSO. DEPENDING ON
WHETHER THEY HAVE CHILDREN AT
HOME. AND WHETHER THERE'S CHILD
CARE FOR THEIR CHILDREN AND WE
KNOW THAT THE PANDEMIC ALSO
CLOSED MOSTRO CARE FACILITIES
OR WHETHER SCHOOLS ARE OPEN.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE'RE
JUST BEGINNING TO GET OUR
SCHOOLS BACK OPEN. SO WE COULD
FACE A SITUATION WHERE SOME
WOMEN WHEN THEIR EMPLOYER
OFFERS IT BACK TO HIM OR NOT IN
A POSITION TO BE ABLE TO
EXERCISE THE CHOICE. TO TAKE
THE JOB ACT WHICH I THINK WOULD
BE VERY UNFORTUNATE. BUT THERE
IS NOT ANY THEN. RESPONSIBILITY
ON EMPLOYERS IF THE PERSON IS
OFFERED THE JOB AND THEY CHOOSE
NOT TO THE EMPLOYER CAN PROCEED
WITH HIRING SOMEONE ELSE. NOW I
WOULD HOPE THAT IN THAT WE CAN
THESE THINGS CAN ALL KIND OF A
LINE IN THE TRIAL CARE BEGINS
TO GET OPEN AGAIN ALSO. AND I
THINK WE'VE A- WE AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE BEEN
ACTING TO PROVIDE SOME MORE
FUNDING. IN ORDER TO HELP
ENSURE THAT CHILD CARE SAVING
TO GET CHILD CARE BACK OPEN WE
KNOW THAT WE'VE ACTED TO HELP
OUR SCHOOLS GET BACK OPEN. SO
HOPEFULLY THESE THINGS A LINE.
SO THAT FOR EXAMPLE AND WOMEN
ARE NOT THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT
HAVE AG CHILD. CARE
RESPONSIBILITIES AT HOME BUT
CERTAIN PRIMARILY. HOPEFULLY
THESE THINGS A LINE SO THAT
WHEN PEOPLE ARE OFFERED THEIR
JOBS BACK THEY CAN TAKE THEM.
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT OF
COURSE IS THAT. THEY WOULD BE
OFFERED THEIR JOBS BACK AND GET
THE SAME TYPE OF WAGE. THAT
THEY RECEIVED. PRIOR WHEN THEY
LAID OFF. INTERESTINGLY DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION. OLDER
WORKERS NOW WE'RE TALKING AGES
FORTY FIVE AND ABOVE. WERE LAID
OFF AT A HIGHER RATE. LOWER
WAGE WORKERS NOT AS NOT
EXECUTIVE BUT LOWER WAGE WERE
LAID OFF AT A HIGHER RATE THAN
YOUNGER. AND ON AVERAGE PICKED
UP TO A YEAR TO GET ANOTHER
JOB. COMPARED TO WORKERS WHO
WERE FORTY AND YOUNGER WHO ON
THE AVERAGE TOOK NINETEEN TO
TWENTY WEEKS. THE ADDITIONAL
FACTOR IS THAT THOSE OLDER
WORKERS DURING THE RECESSION
WHO WERE LAID OFF. AND IT TOOK
ON AVERAGE A YEAR TO GET
ANOTHER JOB THERE SAID NEXT JOB
AFTER THAT LONG PERIOD OF
UNEMPLOYMENT WAS AT A FAR LOWER
WAGE THAN THEIR PREVIOUS JOB
NOT SO WITH THE YOUNGER
WORKERS. SO WHEN YOU IMAGINE I
THINK ANY OF US AS WE GET.
CLOSER TOWARDS RETIREMENT. WE
ARE HOPING THAT WE ARE NOT
GOING BACKWARDS IN TERMS OF
OUR- INCOME OR CONTRIBUTIONS TO
SOCIAL SECURITY SINCE THAT IS
WHAT'S GOING TO BE OUR
RETIREMENT SECURITY. SO I THINK
THIS WHEN WE LOOK AT. WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION AND IF WE WANT TO TRY
TO PREVENT SIMILAR CONSEQUENCES
AS TO NOW AND WHEN WE ALSO LOOK
AT THE MANY OF THE WOMEN IN
THIS CATEGORY OF WORK. FIVE NOT
IN ALL CASES BY ANY MEANS BUT A
LOT OF THEM ARE THE SOLE HEAD
OF HOUSEHOLD AND HAVE DEPENDENT
CHILDREN. SO THEY'RE- EITHER IF
THEY DO NOT GET BACK INTO WORK
WHERE THEY ARE PAID COMPARABLE
TO WHAT THEY WERE BEFORE. AND
ALSO HAVE GREAT IMPACTS ON
THEIR CHILDREN SO. FOR THOSE
REASONS I WILL BE SUPPORTING.
THIS LEGISLATION AND I
APPRECIATE THAT IT IS BEEN
NARROWED AND HAS A SUNSET AND
ALSO WOULD ONLY GOING TO
AFFECT. INSIDE IN RELATION TO
THE SERIOUS EMERGENCIES LIKE
THIS PANDEMIC. MILANESI SAID A
CENTER RECORDS COULD YOU HAVE
YOUR MAKE UP. NO OKAY I THOUGHT
I SAW MIKE UP. AS SENATOR- CHAU
BOOK. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK I JUST HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION- RIGHT. IS THERE A
REASON WHY- THIS BILL DOES NOT
PROVIDE A RIGHT TO Q. WERE FOR
EMPLOYERS PRIOR TO GOING
STRAIGHT TO PENALTIES OF UP TO
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS. PER
EMPLOYEE PER DAY AND ENFORCED
BY THE LABOR COMMISSIONER- I
UNDERSTAND THAT HALF OF THE
LOCAL ORDERS ON THIS PARTICULAR
TOPIC ALLOW FOR A FIFTEEN DAY
RIGHT TO CURE- THAT WOULD AT
LEAST BE A REASONABLE STEPS TO
BEGIN WITH. THE BERMAN OF
FINANCE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADDRESS THAT. YES LET ME TURN
IT OVER TO- ROBERT VILLA LOBOS-
WELL WE PRETTY MUCH YOU TO
REVIEW THE JOB THE BILL. IN A
LANGUAGE AS YOU KNOW WELL AS IT
IS AND- ONE OF THE THINGS WE
DID NOTICE THAT THERE WERE
LOCAL ORDINANCES THAT WOULD
PROVIDE FOR THE- RIGHT TO KEEP
YOUR- THE ONE ASPECT OF IT I
THINK THAT PRESENTS PROBLEMS IS
THAT IT IMPOSES A REQUIREMENT.
ON WORKERS TO YOU KNOW TO
COMPLY TO INITIATE- YOU KNOW HE
THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO BE
REHIRED. AND THAT YOU KNOW CAN
BE PERCEIVED AS A AS A SOMEONE.
ONEROUS REQUIREMENT FOR LOW
WAGE WORKERS AND GOD SAW THAT
THE YOU KNOW THE ABSENCE OF
THAT LANGUAGE YOU KNOW IN THIS
BILL YOU KNOW SEEM TO. BE MORE
APPROPRIATE- THAT IS THAT IS A
SENSE THAT- YOU KNOW OUR OFFICE
SADDAM HAD WITH RESPECT TO THE
ABSENCE OF A RIGHT TO CURE
PROVISION. SENDER TERRIBLE YOU
HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION I WOULD
YES MADAM CHAIR FRED- SO WOULD
IT BE. WOULD IT BE BEST-
PERHAPS PURSUED FROM AN
EMPLOYER'S PERSPECTIVE TO. C.
OR REQUEST A MEANS OF- HAVING
A- THE ABILITY TO HAVE THE
RIGHT TO CURE AB A REQUEST I
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
STATING THAT YOUR CONCERN WAS
FROM THE EMPLOYEES- PROVOCATIVE
BEING THAT I HAVE A AN EXTRA
STEP TO TAKE WOULD IT BE BEST
IF IT WAS- STARTED FROM THE
EMPLOYERS. SPECTATOR INGLE. I
WOULD. WELL I MEAN WE REALLY
WORK LOOKING AFTER YOU KNOW THE
SPECIFIC PROBLEM YOU KNOW
POLICY- WELL YOU KNOW PROS AND
CONS IN TERMS OF WHAT COULD BE
UTILIZED TO YOU KNOW TO. ADD TO
THE EXISTING PROVISIONS OR THE
CURRENT PROVISION OF THE BILL-
IT IS SO WHICH IS IT WE WERE
LOOKING AT IN TERMS OF JUST
WHAT. YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT EXISTS
AND- YOU KNOW SAW THAT THERE
WAS SOME IT WAS A REASONABLE
POSITION TO HAVE- OR WERE TO
NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO CURE
PROVISION IN THE BILL- SO ARE
YOU HI. I JUST UNABLE TO REALLY
ANSWER WHETHER- THAT COULD BE
VIEWED AS YOU KNOW BY OTHERS-
INCLUDING THE LEGISLATIVE BODY
AS AS BEING THAT THE POLICY-
TATE YOU KNOW FOR. THAT ISSUE.
IF I COULD TO SAID QUICKLY ED
MR LOS DOESN T. ISN'T MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
PROCESS FOR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER IS A QUICK
RESOLUTION TO COMPLAINTS AND
GIVEN THAT THIS IS A SHORT
DURATION IS THAT WHAT MIGHT
THAT HAVE BEEN CERTAINLY SHE
COULD SPEAK TO THAT PROCESS
BECAUSE NEEDED YES YES YES WITH
THAT THAT'S CERTAINLY- YOU NO
LONGER WOULD FACTOR IN AND
UNDER THE AFORESAID PROVISIONS-
YOU KNOW AGENTS IN TERMS OF OUR
FEEL GOOD FOR SPENT WHERE. WE
WOULD BE LOOKING TO ENFORCE THE-
PERHAPS THIS PENALTY OR LIQUID
DAMAGES. R. ONCE OUR OFFICE
RECEIVES A COMPLAINT. THERE
THERE'S EARLY INTERVENTION- WE
WOULD BE CONTACTING THE
EMPLOYER YOU KNOW WE- WOULD
ALSO IS PART OF OUR TOOLS OF
FROM. THE PRECEDING WE CAN
ISSUE A NOTICE TO DISCONTINUE
OUR PRIOR TO. ACTUALLY
DETERMINING WHETHER K<c.cyan> A</c>
CIVIL PENALTY AND LIQUIDATED
DAMAGES IS THE APPROPRIATE
REMEDY- IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
FILING OF A CLAIM FOR
INDIVIDUAL RELIEF SUCH AS THE
REINSTATEMENT OF THE FRONT AND
THE BACK HEY YOU KNOW THE- THE
VALUE OF THE BENEFITS. BUT
AGAIN YOU KNOW. ONCE THE
COMPLAINT COMES TO US NO THERE
WOULD BE A NOTIFICATION TO THE
EMPLOYER- THAT THERE WAS AN
INVESTIGATION YOU KNOW. AND
HOMES SOLD YOU KNOW IN BOTH
CASES THERE'S A REASONABLY.
QUICK OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
EMPLOYER TO. YOU KNOW TO- HIGHS
YOU KNOW IT ITS LIABILITY WITH
RESPECT TO THE INDIVIDUAL
RELIEF. FOR A VOID PERHAPS YOU
KNOW THE- CIVIL PENALTY
LIQUIDATED DAMAGES BY BEING
INFORMED THAT- THAT THEY NEED
TO COMPLY. MR LEWIS'S GIVEN
THAT SENATOR OCHO BOOKS
QUESTION WAS ABOUT THE RIGHT TO
CURE AND PLEASE CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG BUT MY THINK MY
UNDERSTANDING IS ISN'T THE
RIGHT PICTURE ASSOCIATED WITH
PROGRESS. IN THE- THE RIGHT OF
THE EMPLOYEE TO SUE AND ISN'T
THE ELIMINATION OF PAGA MEANING
THE FACT THAT THIS BILL THIS
ELIMINATES THAT YOU DO NOT HAVE
THAT RIGHT DOES THE EMPLOYEE
DOES NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO SUE.
THAT THAT IS A FACTOR IN
WHETHER YOU NEED WHETHER THE
RIGHT THE- TIME IS NECESSARY.
WELL CERTAINLY THERE ARE
PROVISIONS IN PART ABOUT WHICH-
YOU KNOW WHICH ARE CURABLE.
BEHIND SO AND I NOTICE WOULD
HAVE TO GO YOU KNOW WELL BE
MADE TO THE EMPLOYER- AND THAT.
SHOULD MAYBE THAT ONE OF THE
UNDERLYING. PRINCIPLES OR
CONCEPTS THAT- LOCAL ORDINANCES
WERE LOOKING AT- PRIOR TO
IMPOSING LIABILITY- SO YOU YES
I THINK THE ABSENCE OF. ANY
OBJECT ABILITY TO PAGO- YOU
KNOW- IS IT SOMEWHAT TELLING-
AND SO. I WOULD SAY THAT THAT'S
YOU KNOW THAT CERTAINLY WOULD.
BE A FACTOR- SENATOR JOE BERGIN
CAN HAVE THE FLOOR AGAIN I JUST
I WAS TRYING TO SINCE YOU ASKED
ABOUT THE RIGHT TO CURE I
THOUGHT. PERHAPS HE HAD NOT
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT ASPECT BUT-
I WASN'T SURE IF MY INFORMATION
WAS CORRECT OR NOT BUT POLICE
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER FURTHER QUESTIONS.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE ACTION APPRECIATE AS
A FRESHMAN SENATOR HERE FOR SHE
AND FEEDBACK AND SUPPORT FROM
ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES. IN
CONVEYING MY QUESTIONS AND MY
IDEAS SO THANK YOU- SO IJUST
WANT TO JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
PURPOSES WANT TO MAKE SURE I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE. I UNDERSTAND.
THIS W STILL HAVE WITHIN THIS
BILL THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
BUSINESSES TO. HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE ABILITY
TO- BASICALLY. MEET WHATEVER
THE REQUIREMENT FOR THE- WOULD
YOU SAY THE CLAIM WOULD BE
BEFORE ANY PUNITIVE- MEASURES
ARE IMPLEMENTED OUR PURSUIT. DO
YOU THINK WOULD IN SO FAR AS AS
I AS I PREVIOUSLY- EXPRESS IT
WOULD BE YOU KNOW HOW THE PARTY
NOTIFICATION TO THE EMPLOYER-
OF A COLORFUL VIOLATION OR
POTENTIAL VIOLATION THAT WE
WOULD BE INVESTIGATING. AND HOW
TO THAT EXTENT THAT MAY FOR
CLOTHES OR- WORSE CERTAINLY TO
BE CONSIDERED IN EVALUATING
WHETHER THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
WOULD PROCEED TO COLLECT THIS
CIVIL PENALTY A LIQUIDATED
DAMAGES- WITH RESPECT TO THE-
INDIVIDUAL RECOVERY ON THE
REINSTATEMENT- AS WELL AS THE
BACK PAY YOU KNOW THAT. WOULD
BE SOMETHING THAT- THEY WOULD
CERTAINLY BE A TO. ANY SORT OF-
ACTUAL DAMAGES THAT LABOR
COMMISSIONER MIKE RECEIVE
AGAINST THE EMPLOYER. BUT YOU
KNOW WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT. THE
NOTIFICATION CAN MINIMIZE THIS
AND IN THAT WE REALLY ARE ARE
TRYING TO MOVE TOWARDS THE
UNDERLYING INTENT OF THE BILL
WHICH IS TO. IT'LL FORD. PLAYED
OFF WORKERS THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
YOU KNOW NEEDS TO BE REAPPLIED
INCOMPLETE. WITH HER FORMER
EMPLOYER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WELCOME SENATOR NIELSEN. NOPE
MANAGER I'M GOING TO RE VISIT
THE POLICY ISSUE OF. A
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
TALKED AT LENGTH HEALTH
THOROUGHLY THIS WAS DEBATED
LAST YEAR. AND THAT WOULD BEEN
AS A POLICY BILL I'D LIKE TO
ASK THEN FINANCE WHY IS THE
ADMINISTRATION ADVANCING THIS
NOW AS A TRAILER BILL RATHER
THAN AS A POLICY BILL. I'M
GONNA HAVE TO TURN THAT OVER TO
YOU- CHRIS COOK. GOOD MORNING
CHRIS COOK WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- CENTER NIELSEN TO YOUR
QUESTION AND AS PREVIOUSLY
STATED- SB EIGHTY FOUR IS VERY
SIMILAR TO THE BILL THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED LAST YEAR AB
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN. WHICH WAS
AGAIN SUBSEQUENTLY VETOED BY
THE GOVERNOR- IN THIS MESSAGE
THE GOVERNOR SHARED HIS
CONCERNS AND ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER OTHER
APPROACHES- SO THAT THAT NO
WORKERS ARE LEFT BEHIND- AS THE
ECONOMY REOPENS AND AS WE'VE
KIND OF NOTED SEVERAL TIMES
THIS MORNING. THAT YOU KNOW THE
ECONOMY IS HOPEFUL THAT'LL BE
REOPEN IN THE COMING MONTHS AND
SO AFTER DISCUSSIONS- MANY OF
THOSE CONCERNS ARE ADDRESSED IN
THIS BILL- A BEAUTY FOR WHICH-
AS NOTED- BY A COUPLE MEMBERS
THIS MORNING THAT WAS
THOROUGHLY DEBATED. LAST YEAR-
MORE SPECIFICALLY THOSE THOSE
THOSE- ELEMENTS THAT WERE
ADDRESSED IS THE ELIMINATED-
THE REQUIREMENT FOR THE
EMPLOYEE TO YOU KNOW PROVIDE
CERTAIN. INFORMATION AND THEN
ALSO IT NEARLY DEFINE THE
COLGATE- STATED THE MARGIN C.
AS BEING THAT THE TARGET FOR
THIS SO IT VERY NARROWLY-
CRAFTED AT AB EIGHTY FOUR. I
THANK SIR BUT I UNDERSTAND
DEATHS IN THERE IRRELEVANT
ANSWER. WHATEVER HAPPENED LAST
YEAR DOES NOT APPLY TO THIS
YEAR. WHAT FLIES AND WHAT
COUNTS IS WHAT WE DEAL WITH NOW.
AND WHAT THE BILL DOES SAY IN
THE PROCESS THROUGH WHICH IT.
TRANSCEND TRANSCEND THE PROCESS.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
GOING TO REQUIRE ME TO GO TO
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL AND GET A
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL OPINION.
I'M NOT SATISFIED WITH THE
RESPONSE. LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANY MORE. MIKE SUB CENTER
CORTESE. WE CAN MANAGER I JUST
SAW A WONDERFUL- PHONE- MY
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS REGARDING.
RIGHT TO CURE THE BILL IT READS
LIKE A STRIP CLUB BILITY.
PROCESS AS OPPOSED TO A RIGHT
TO CARE BUT I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE. THE GENERAL
ADMINISTRATION- OR PROCESS TO
PROCESS THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE WOULD USE
SO. I THINK SOME OF. SOME OF
OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE RAISED THE
ISSUE OF. NUANCE OF YOU KNOW
SHOULD NOT GOING AFTER FOLKS
WHO ARE- BUT PERHAPS HAVE
CHANGED OUR BUSINESS MODEL HAVE
SOME SORT OF. ISSUE BEYOND.
WHAT THE COMPLAINT IS BECAUSE
KOHLI NOW ON V. P. N. PLEASE
COMPLAIN. IN A I DON'T KNOW IF-
IF- LABOR COMMISSIONER I MEAN
OF THEIR LABOR COMMISSION
REPRESENTATIVE CAN. VERY
QUICKLY AND IF IT CAN'T BE DONE
QUICKLY I SUPPOSE IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL INFORMATION TO HELP
OFFLINE WE'RE VOTING TODAY SO
I'D PREFER TO HEAR IT NOW. YOU
KNOW A SORT OF A THREE MINUTE.
OVERVIEW OF. OF WHAT THE
PROCESS. WOULD IT WILL ACTUALLY
DO COMPLAINT COMES IN WE KNOW
THAT PART- I'M NOT CLEAR AFTER
THAT WHETHER A COMPLIANCE ORDER
IS THEN ISSUED- TO THE EMPLOYER.
WHETHER RIGHT TO A HEARING IS
ISSUED. AND IF SO. ARE THEY AT
THAT POINT. JUST PUSHING BACK
ON ON WAGES OR DO THEY STILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THE ENTIRE PENALTY VITIATED
DURING DURING THAT PROCESS MEET
SOME FROM GETTING THERE HAS TO
BE SOME ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS.
PRISON MINIMUM THE MINISTRY OF
LAW PROCESS SOME KIND OF A
HEARING. A BASED ON ASSUME SOME
KIND OF A COMPLIANCE ORDER. I
DON'T WANT TO ATTEMPT. TO
CONFUSE THINGS HERE MYSELF BY
TRYING TO CREATE A PROCESS I
JUST LIKE TO HEAR. WHAT IS THAT
PROCESS AND AT WHAT POINT. IT
DOES- A MISUNDERSTANDING OR
MISAPPLICATION. OF THE
COMPLAINT PROCESS- GET GET AN
EMPLOYER OFF THE HOOK ON. ON
THE PENALTIES THAT ARE CALLED
OF LEGISLATION WHICH IN THE
LEGISLATION AGAIN LOOKALIKES
FOR GLOBAL BE PENALTIES. YES
LIKE I COULD I COULD SPEAK TO.
YOU KNOW TO- THAT TO IN IN THE
RESPECT THAT THE ENFORCEMENT-
PROVISION IN THE BILL. REFERS
TO EXISTING ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HAS HISTORICALLY
UTILIZED- ENDED IN THE
IMPLICATES THE YOU KNOW TWO OF
OUR INVESTIGATIVE PROGRAMS- AND
THAT IS OUR FEELING PERCENT
PROGRAM- AS WELL AS THE HER
RETALIATION COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATION UNIT. BOTH
DOUBLED- THEIR RESOURCES TO.
INVESTIGATION AND- THAT
INVESTIGATION IS THE SPEAKING
TO THE PARTIES INVOLVED WHETHER
THAT BE YOU KNOW THE CURRENT
EMPLOYER OR A SUCCESSOR
EMPLOYER UNDER THIS BILL.
CANADA MINISTRY DETERMINATION
WOULD THEN BE MADE INDICTED
MINISTRY DETERMINATION WOULD BE
IN THE FORM OF A CITATION IT
WAS ISSUED BY OUR FIELD
ENFORCEMENT UNIT. OR IT WOULD
BE. DETERMINATION UNDER- THE-
ACTUALLY NINETY EIGHT POINT
SEVEN UNDER THE RETALIATION
COMPLAINT. PROCESS SO- THERE
WOULD BE A FINDING AND KNOWS
WHAT CONSTITUTES ADMINISTRATIVE
FINDINGS.AND ON THE SURFACE
CITATION FRONT. OF THE EMPLOYER
CAN THEN REQUEST A HEARING.
BEFORE THE HEARING OFFICER SAID
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S UNIT.
WHO WOULD ISSUE A
DETERMINATION- AFTER HEARING
EVIDENCE PRESENTED BY BOTH
SIDES THAT IS ALSO SUBJECT TO
REVIEW BY A COURT IF AN
EMPLOYER. IS UNSATISFIED WITH
pINDIVIDUAL RELIEF- ARM ABOVE
THE REMEDIES UNDER THIS
SECTION. OF THE DETERMINATION
THAT WOULD BE ISSUED BY THE%
LABOR COMMISSIONER- WOULD BE
SENT TO THE EMPLOYER ANY
SUCCESSOR EMPLOYERS THAT. ARE
APPROPRIATE. AND THEN YOU KNOW
IN ORDER TO ENFORCE THAT WE
WOULD FILE A LAWSUIT YOU KNOW
IN- IN SUPERIOR COURT IN ORDER
TO. YOU KNOW TOO WELL AND FORCE
THAT ADMINISTRATIVE
DETERMINATION. SO BECAUSE-
EXISTENTIALLY DUE PROCESS THAT
WOULD BE EMBODIED IN THE FUTURE
JUST A POLL QUESTION MR THE
LOBOS IS IT YOUR- UNDERSTANDING
OF. THE PROCESS THAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED THAT THE HEARING
OFFICER WOULD RETAIN ULTIMATE
DISCRETION OVER. WHETHER
PENALTIES. OUR KERN FORCED OR
NOT THE SYSTEM FORCE OR NOT IS
THAT HEARING OFFICER IN YOUR
MIND TO DO THIS BILL STILL
RETAIN. DISCRETION TO MAKE A
DECISION. ABSOLUTELY YOU KNOW
THE HEARING OFFICER HIS YOU
KNOW FUNCTIONS YOU KNOW WHAT IT
INDEPENDENT OF THE
INVESTIGATION SO THEY WOULD BE
BASING THEIR DETERMINATION NO
ON THE EVIDENCE PRESENTED BY
BOTH PARTIES- AT THE AT THE AT
THE HEARING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MANAGER. THIRTY
FIVE A QUICK CLARIFICATION YOU
YOU REFERENCE THE HEARING BUT
AT THE POINT A COMPLAINT IS
FILED THIS IN THE FIELD NEED
THE EMPLOYER IS INFORMED AND
THE EMPLOYER HAS THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO THE- THE
FIELD. IN OTHER WORDS IT IS IT
IT ISN'T NECESSARILY ALL THE
WAY TO THE PROCESS OF A HEARING
BEFORE THE EMPLOYER IS ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WHAT CARTERET
RESPOND OKAY THAT'S WHAT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE SO THERE'S ALWAYS
THE POSSIBILITY THAT YOU
WOULDN'T EVEN HAVE A HEARING
THAT IN OTHER WORDS. LET'S SAY
I MAKE THE COMPLAINT AND THE
FIELD INVESTIGATORS INVESTIGATE
THE EMPLOYER SUBMITS
INFORMATION THAT THE
INVESTIGATOR FEELS- CONTRADICTS
THAT WHICH WAS PROVIDED THE
COMPLAINT DEPENDING ON HOW YOU
KNOW THE EXTENT OF THAT- THE
THOROUGHNESS OF IT THE FIELD
INVESTIGATOR COULD DENY A
WITHOUT NECESSARILY IT HAVING
TO GO TO A HEARING. IS NEXT SIR.
YES YES THAT IS CORRECT. SAGAY
YOU KNOW HIS HIS. YOU KNOW
BASED ON THE INFORMATION THAT
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER OBTAINS.
AND THE SELECTED REDUCE. ORDERS
RIGHT. RIGHT CENTER CORTESE
CERTAINLY IF YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS GO AHEAD.
HELLO YOU KNOW THE ONLY
QUESTION OTHER QUESTION I HAVE
THANK YOU FOR IT FOR ASKING
DONE I WAS JUST ABOUT TO SEE
THE FLOOR HERE OF MR VIDEO
LOBOS IS- TO UP TO WHAT EXTENT.
HAS THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE BEEN ABLE TO TWO-
CALCULATOR ANTICIPATE- SB
NEEDED- YOU KNOW TO YOU KNOW TO
BASICALLY EXECUTE ON THIS
PROGRAM- IF THIS BECOMES LAW
AND I. LET ME JUST PUT KNOW
THAT AND SAY I THINK WE ALL
UNDERSTAND- THAT THOSE
PROJECTIONS WOULD BE
SPECULATIVE- AT BEST BUT I'M
I'M JUST WARNED IF. HE WERE
OFFICES RUN THROUGH ANY
CALCULATIONS ON THAT AT ALL IN
TERMS OF JUST HER OWN CAPACITY
TO KEEP UP WITH THE POTENTIAL
OF DEMAND THE APPLICATION
PROCESS. THAT THAT WE MIGHT
ANTICIPATE FROM THE SAW. THANK
YOU JUST GENERALLY STATE TO
THAT YOU KNOW WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER RECOGNIZES THAT-
FOCUSED RESOURCES WOULD HAVE
TO. YOU KNOW BE APPLIED HE WENT
OVER TO COMPLEMENT THIS BILL
WILL BE GIVEN THE- THE CLEAR
INTENT OF IT. HANDS HE DOES
THAT WOULD REQUIRE US TO YOU
KNOW- PRIOR TOR PRIORITIZE
COMPLAINTS BY WORKERS IN THIS
INDUSTRY- THAT IT WILL. GET
INVOLVED IN A PUBLIC OUTREACH.
NO LONGER YOU KNOW TO INFORM
BOTH THE EMPLOYEE AND EMPLOYER
COMMUNITIES. OF FONG. ABOVE
THESE RECRUITMENT REQUIREMENTS.
AND OTHER WE WOULD HAVE TO
CLEARLY PUT ON OUR WEBSITE. YOU
KNOW- DIRECTION. FAQS WHICH
WOULD- YOU KNOW PROVIDE A YOUNG.
SOURCE FOR THE POP TO CONSOLE
AND IN DETERMINE THEIR-
OBLIGATIONS AND- RIGHTS UNDER
THE STEEP SECTION- FIGURE AGAIN
FUTURE IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'VE
DONE SOME WORK ON THAT I GUESS
WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR IS WHETHER
OR NOT YOU ANTICIPATE THE NEED
FOR AUGMENTATION. OR NOT AT
THIS POINT- COLLEAGUES AT THE.
LET ME REPHRASE THE FRIEND THAT
IS A QUESTION DO YOU NEED
AUGMENTATION TO KEEP UP WITH
THE DEMAND OF THIS PROGRAM
THERE IS AN APPROPRIATION IN
THE BILL- I AM- YOU CERTAINLY
CAN HEAR HIS RESPONSE BUT I'M
ASSUMING THAT THEY'VE MADE SOME
ESTIMATION OF WHAT THEY FELT
MIGHT. WHAT ADITIONAL
RESOURCES THEY MAY NEED LIMIT
I'M SURE THAT THANK YOU FOR.
REFRAMING THE QUESTION- BUT I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
WE CAN OFFER LET ME PAUSE AND
SAY I DON'T TRYING TO- DRAW
THIS TODAY'S HEARING OUT ANY
FURTHER THAN WE NEED TO WE'RE
TRYING TO MOVE THINGS FORWARD I
THINK I PERSONALLY THAT'S MY
INTENT. ON THE OTHER HAND THERE
CERTAINLY BEEN A CHALLENGE AT
TIMES DURING COLD RESPONSE
HELLO FOR THE STATE TO
ESSENTIALLY PROHIBIT OR TURN ON
A DIME IN IT CAN RAMP UP THE F.
T. E. THAT'S NECESSARY- TO DEAL
WITH- LAWS THAT CAN EVEN
AUGMENTATION THAT'S A REALLY
ACTION OR LAWS THAT TAKE EFFECT
LIKE THIS ONE WOULD IMMEDIATELY
AND FM CONSCIOUS WORKING FOR
SOME ASSURANCE. THE. WITH THE
APPROPRIATION. THAT ARCHER JUST
REFERRED ME TO. THEY YOU ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO STAFF UP
THIS TO PUT IT IN PLAIN ENGLISH
QUICKLY ENOUGH. TO DEAL WITH
THE NEEDS OF THE PROGRAM. CHRIS
COOK HAD HIS HAND UP SO LET ME
CALL ON HIM TO- TO SEE IF HE
HAS AN ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION
OR WHETHER WE GO BACK TO
CONSISTENT LABOR COMMISSION GO
AHEAD. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATOR QUESTION YES
WE BELIEVE THAT WITH THE
RESOURCE IS INCLUDED IN THE
BILL AND- THE DVR'S CAPACITY
THAT THEY THEY CAN. USE THESE
RESOURCES AND THEIR ABILITY TO
ENFORCE- THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL. FRIEDMAN I'M SURE THE
TOYOTA. THREE PART. IT'S HARD
SOMETIMES TO SEE WITH THE- I
HAVE PLASTIC IN FRONT OF YOU
ALL OF MANY DO AND- THE
REFLECTION CENTER NIELSEN.
MADAM CHAIR BEING MINDFUL THAT
THE THIS BILL IS GOING TO MOVE
ON A FAST TRACK- THIS YEAR. I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT WE- HAVE
WHICH COUNCIL SUMMONS HERE THIS
IS BEEN DONE BEFORE OFTEN
SUMMONS TO THE COMMITTEE. AND
WE CAN- HAVE MAJORITY STAFF AND
MINORITY STAFF TALK WITH THAT
COUNCILLOR I WOULD TALK AND-
GIVEN THE QUESTION. REGARDING
POLICY VERSUS TRAILER BILL AND
THEN HAVE THAT QUESTION BE
POSED BEFORE THE FULL BODY THAT
WE MIGHT AND- KNOW WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE THAT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION. AND I'M
TRYING TO SET UP A LEGAL BASIS
FOR LAWSUITS ABOUT THESE KINDS
OF THINGS BECAUSE WE'RE GETTING
THE TOO MUCH OF A HABIT OF THIS
AROUND HERE. CENTER NIELSEN YOU
CERTAINLY ARE ENTITLED TO MAKE
THAT REQUEST OF LEDGECOUNCIL
I'M NOT GONNA ASK THEM TO COME.
TO OUR COMMITTEE WHEN WE STILL
HAVE ANOTHER BILL TO HEAR
BECAUSE THEY MAY. DESIRE TO
HAVE A LONGER PERIOD OF
DELIBERATION. THIS IS NOT
SCHEDULED TO BE VOTED ON ON THE
FLOOR TODAY SO WE CERTAINLY
HAVE TIME TO GET IF THE- F YOU
MAKE SUCH A REQUEST TO GET AN
ANSWER. FROM THEM SO YOU'RE A
CONSENTING THAT WE WILL BRING
TO COUNCIL AND BUT NOT I DID
NOT CONSENT TO BRING THE
COUNCIL AND I SAID YOU MAY MAKE
A REQUEST OF COUNCIL BUT I AM
NOT GOING TO ASK COUNCIL TO
COME HERE AND WE DON'T NEED
MORE MADAM CHAIR. THAT MAY BE
THE CASE. BUT I AM NOT AWARE OF
THAT. MANDATE UNDER ON THE LINE
RECOGNIZE OBJECTION I DO NOT
BELIEVE THIS IS A PROPER POLICY
THE- BILL A ROUGH PROPER.
BUDGET TRAILER BILL. AND I WILL
SEEK LET'S COUNCIL OPINION.
SEPARATE FIRST LET ME SEE-
CENTER DOLLY DO YOU KNOW OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. WE ARE GOING TO. GO
TO THE NEXT BILL. AND OF COURSE
AFTER THAT HAVE PUBLIC HEARING
IN A PUBLIC COMMENTS GOING
COME. POLICIES WITH THE C. ALL
RIGHT SIR WE WILL NOW MOVES. TO
THE. NEXT BILL WHICH IS AB
TWENTY TWO ONE THREE THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS CLEAN UP
WHATEVER THE ADMINISTRATION OR
DO YOU REPRESENT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AB EIGHTY EIGHT
ENACTED IN LATE FEBRUARY
ESTABLISHED TO GOLDEN STATE
GRANT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE ONE
TIME GRANT PAYMENTS IN THE
AMOUNT OF SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
TO QUALIFYING LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS ON THE SS I SS P.
AND CASH ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
THE AGED. BLIND AND DISABLED.
MS KNOWN AS THE CAPPY PROGRAM.
IN HOUSEHOLDS ON THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM. AT THAT TIME WAS
ENVISIONED AT THE SOCIAL
SECURITY ADMINISTRATION WOULD
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM BUT
AFTER DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
SOCIAL SECURITY ADMINISTRATION
WE LEARNED IT WAS UNABLE TO DO
SO. THIS BILL INCLUDES CLEAN UP
PROVISIONS THAT ENABLE THE
STATE TO ADMINISTER THE ONE
TIME GOLDEN STATE GRANT
PAYMENTS TO ELIGIBLE RECIPIENTS.
THE BILL ALSO EXTENDS THE
CAPPING VERBAL ATTESTATION
FLEXIBILITIES. END OF THE STATE
OF EMERGENCY DUE TO THE CLUB IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THIS ****
FLEXIBILITY IS CURRENTLY NEEDED
TO SUPPORT THE CAPPY APPLICANTS
GIVEN THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION'S OFFICES REMAIN
CLOSED TO THE PUBLIC IT ALSO
PROVIDES THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY TO CONTACT
RECIPIENTS OF PROGRAMS THE
DEPARTMENT OVERSEES NOTIFY THEM
OF POTENTIAL ELIGIBILITY. FOR
OTHER LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
BENEFITS INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO YOUR INCOME. AND
FEDERAL TAX STIMULUS CREDITS.
CURRENT STATE STATUTE DOES NOT
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT SO
SERVICES TO INFORM ITS
RECIPIENTS OF OTHER POTENTIAL
BENEFITS AND HOW TO RECEIVE
ASSISTANCE TO CLAIM THEM
PROPOSED TOUCH TO A CHANGE CAN
HELP MAXIMIZE THE BENEFITS AND
SUPPORTS TO BE THAT THESE
RECIPIENTS RECEIVE. FINALLY
THIS BILL PROVIDES ONE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND TO ALLOW EMERGENCY
PLACEMENT FOSTER CARE GIVERS TO
CONTINUE TO BE PAID. BEYOND THE
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY. INSTANCES
WITH A FOSTER PARENT APPROVAL
PROCESS HAS BEEN DELAYED DUE TO
COVER NINETEEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU LET ME SEE
IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS. SEEING.
NINE- YES I THINK THAT THIS ONE
IS PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD IN
THAT- WE'VE APPROVED THIS AND
WE WANNA MAKE SURE THESE FUNDS
GET OUT IN THE WAY THAT WE
INTENDED AND CLEARLY- A FEW OF
THE CATEGORIES NEEDED TO-
INTERACT WITH THEM FEDERAL
RULES AND SUCH SO. I APPRECIATE
YOUR- PRESENTATION. AND THE
CLARIFICATION AND AGAIN SEEING
YOU KNOW A- MIKE SAP. WE WILL
THEN. GO TO OUR PUBLIC COMMENT.
SO WE'LL START WITH FOLKS THAT
ARE IN THE ROOM BUT LET ME
JUST- ALERT FOLKS THAT THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN
THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE ONE.
DAN TODAY BECAUSE WE HEARD ALL
THREE BILLS AND THE CALLERS WHO
ARE CALLING IN MAYBE COOK
CALLING IN ON YOU KNOW ONE OR
MORE- AND WE'RE NOT GONNA
SEPARATED. THEN WE WILL ALSO
TAKE THE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF THE
THREE BILLS SIMULTANEOUSLY SO
IN OTHER WORDS MODERATOR WE
WILL NOT BE DISTINGUISHING
PEOPLE DO NOT HAVE TO SEPARATE
THEMSELVES IN THE QUEUE. TO
SUPPORTER TO OPPOSITION OR TO
WHAT BILL WE CAN JUST TAKE
THEIR COMMENT AND THEY CAN BE
CLEAR ABOUT WHICH BILL THEY ARE
SPEAKING TO AND WHETHER THEY
ARE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION-
AND I'M ASKING EACH MEMBER. TO
PLEASE KEEP THEIR REMARKS
WITHIN ONE MINUTE SO LET'S
BEGIN FIRST WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE GALLERY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
HI YES. MY CA. GO AHEAD MR
MCHALE- MADAM CHECK. IS IT ON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
MCKINLEY ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
AND MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES
BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR AND THE
WILDFIRE FUNDING PACKAGE. WE
ARE HOPEFUL THAT IT IS A DOWN
PAYMENT THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING
WILL BE. A PART OF YOUR JUNE
BUDGET AND WE ALSO HOPE THAT
SOME SIGNIFICANT POLICY- THINGS
ARE ADOPTED AS WELL INCLUDING
PUTTING ONE PERSON IN CHARGE OF
THOSE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES. THAT YOU VIEW BIO MASS
AS PART OF THE SOLUTION FOR
DEALING WITH VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. AND ALSO THAT YOU
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS SO THAT
PRESCRIBED FIRE LIABILITY CAN
BE. USED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU NOW WE WILL
LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE THERE WHO
WISHES TO FOR A- PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE. AND THERE IS NOT
SO- WE WILL NOW MODERATOR YOU
CAN PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT WILL BEGIN. K.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK. PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. THE MODERATOR.
WE HAVE FIFTEEN ALL RIGHT GREAT
YOU CAN OPEN A LINE. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE NINETEEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR OF
MIKE- MIKE WITH THE WESTERN LAW
POVERTY. SPEAKING TODAY ON
SUPPORTER AB. THIRTY WE THINK
THIS A VERY. MADE TO THIS BOOK
AND WE THINK WE'RE GONNA BE
HAVE TO FIGHT HAPPY PERSON- YOU
KNOW WORLD THIS THAT THE OTHER
THING WOULD NOT BE TO COME TO
WAY KEEP ABLE TO PUT THE SHOW
FOUNDER- TO DIVERSIFY. AND WE
ARE COULD AS WE GO FORWARD THIS
AND THERE MAY BE RESEARCH OVER
BE ABLE GET THE MONEY THEY THE
CALL LOCAL THE AB THAT IS. NO
ACCURATE SO WE'RE LOOKING TO
THE PART SOCIAL TO WORK WITH
ADVOCATE BY CARS ANOTHER TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A WAY TO
AND OF THE THAT THE GO FOR WELL
WE DO SO AND WE WERE PRETTY-
THE SUPPORT ONCE IN THE- TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL INCOME FOR
ARE INCLUDED IN THE- PLAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MODERATOR NOW COMMENTED. BUT
ALSO WON IT RIDGE VERY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI TO THIRTEEN
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS. BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE
TO PROVIDE THESE- ONE TIME
GRANT PAYMENTS I ALSO WANT TO
SUPPORT- THE- BAGGAGE JUNIOR
ESPECIALLY THE PROVISIONS
DEALING WITH WILDFIRE RESPONSE
INTERVENTION. IF THAT'S DONE
PROPERLY YOU WILL HAVE A
TREMENDOUSLY- BIG IMPACT PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND SENIORS
AND ALSO THE LOW INCOME WORKERS
WHO PROVIDE SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR DOING THIS YEAR. THANK YOU.
MODERATOR. FINE. THIRTEEN HE'S
NOT BROUGHT ON BE HAPPY HERE IN
THE IN STRONG OF AGING FOR
WHICH IT SAID AIMS MEASURE OUR
MEMBERS NO HAN IN THE- WE'VE
SEEN THE PANDA- HAS USED IN THE
PRE THEY WOULD BRING YOU BACK
OR WORK. WOMEN OF TO THE NEXT
AVAILABLE OF OUR MORE AND JUST
YOU KNOW ON SOME OF THE COMMON.
MEMBERS ABSENT. WE'VE HAD THESE
ORDERS ALL OVER THE STATE. ALL
OVER THE STATE BACK INSTEAD LET
AND YOU CAN EXPECT ALWAYS WORKS%
FINE. AND SO WE WAITED URGE
YOUR SAID. SUPPORT MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE. TO
SIX. MEMBERS AND YOUR THE
CALIFORNIA THE THING FOR
CALLING AND OF AB. ONE A COUPLE
SHOOTING WITH ANOTHER PROGRAM.
OUTREACH DOLLARS IT'S JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT IF THERE IS AN
ADDRESS ISSUE WE HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE FOR
FOLKS TO GET THE HELP THEY NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY THEY GET
THAT CHECK- AND THEN FINALLY I
WOULD JUST URGE THE LEGISLATURE
MINISTRATION TO DO MORE
STIMULUS- TO CONTINUE TO TRY
AND GET THESE CHECKED INTO
EVERY CORNER CALIFORNIA EVERY
COMMUNITY. FOR EXAMPLE- WHAT
ABOUT THOSE AND GENERAL
ASSISTANCE CAN WE WORK WITH THE
COMPANIES FOR THOSE WHO ARE
ATTENDING AT THE SITE LOCATIONS
WE KNOW IT TAKES FOLKS MONTHS
OFTEN YEARS TO GET ON THE AT
THE SITE COMMENTS- JUST
ENCOURAGE THE STATE. TO
CONTINUE TO RESOURCE. FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS AT IT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE. TWENTY
THE MORNING MADAM MA'AM OF THE
JULIE BALLOT BY ON BEHALF OF
THE K. HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION SEEKING TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY EIGHTY FOUR
THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND
LODGING ASSOCIATION BELIEVES AB
EIGHTY FOUR WILL NOT BRING BACK
THE JOBS AT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND EIGHT HOTEL
EMPLOYEE. WRITTEN IN FACT IT
WILL PROBABLY SLOW THE PROCESS
DOWN THAT'S WHY WITHOUT THREE
THREE AMENDMENTS TO BE MADE TO
THIS BILL TO MAKE IT MORE
WORKABLE THEY ARE DETAILED IN A
LETTER WE SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE HOWEVER FOR REALLY
SERIOUS ABOUT BRINGING BACK
THESE EMPLOYEES TO WORK WE NEED
TO DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF GAS. AND DEAL WITH
THE FACT THAT MANY HOTELS STATE
FINANCIAL DISTRESS THEIR NUMBER
WAYS AT THIS LEGISLATURE CAN
HELP THE INDUSTRY AND BRING
BACK THESE EMPLOYEES NUMBER ONE
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET S. B. Q.
EIGHTY FIVE CENTER REQUIRED
BILLS THAT WOULD FUND COLLEEN
ALL CALIFORNIANS. TO INCREASE
TOURISM IN THE STATE. AFTER A
STATE FARM REHAB. AND CENTER
CURRENT. FONG AND AN ACT SIX
WASH D. BRIDGE FOR HERE IT IS
RUN BY LABOR AND INDUSTRY AND
THE MONEY FROM THE PROGRAM CAN
ONLY BE SPENT ON PAYROLL AND
BENEFITS WE NEED TO KEEP THIS
CONVERSATION GOING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY THREE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MONICA TEMERITY ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU PINE.
TWELVE HELLO THIS IS JENNIFER
O'MALLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND STRONG
SUPPORTER OF OUR HOTEL WORKERS
EDT FOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTEEN. PARDON ME JUST A
MOMENT ONE FIFTEEN. FIVE TO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AROUND BOTH SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. OR- A. B. EIGHTY
FOUR I WANTED TO ECHO THE WORDS
OF NOT BROADBAND UNITE HERE AS
WE BEGIN THE RECOVERY PROCESS
FROM THE CURRENT PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY- MANY OF THE WORKERS
THAT THIS BILL WILL HELP OUR
PARENTS OF THE CHILDREN THAT
ARE EDUCATORS TEACH- AND SO
THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO RETURN TO
WORK CREATE STABILITY FOR THE
FAMILIES. OF THE CHILDREN THAT
WE SIR WE ARE YOUR AYE VOTE ON
AB EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU. NINE
TWENTY NINE. THE MORNING CARE
SKINNER AND MEMBERS- JEANNIE
FOR NEWS FOR THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY NINE CAPS
FOR PRESENT SMALL AND MID SCALE
FAMILY FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA
AND HAS WORKED FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS TO PRESERVE FAMILY SCALE
AGRICULTURE AND PROMOTE
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY.
EIGHT FOUR THAT GOVERNOR NATION
PROPOSED AND LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS HAVE AGREED TO INCLUDE
AN EARLY ACTION THE THREE POINT
THREE FIVE MILLION URGENTLY
NEEDED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
HELP SMALL AND MID SIZE. AND
UNDERSERVED FARMERS
SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATE. RIDE AND
EIGHT AND FEDERAL COVERAGE
RELIEF PROGRAMS THIS REAL THIS
RELATIVELY SMALL INVESTMENT BY
THE STATE COULD HELP LEVERAGE
SIGNIFICANTLY A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF THAT ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL RELIEF I
WANT TO EXTEND A SPECIAL THANK
YOU SENATOR EGGMAN THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP DURING
THIS CHALLENGING TIME- THANK
YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU. ONE
TWENTY. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS TERRY ONLY ON THE
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN DIRECTOR
WITH ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT
ACTION I'M HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO ONE THREE AND
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE. FOR BREAKFAST FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO. GETTING
PEOPLE VICTIMLESS OUT TOO. MANY
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS AS
HUMANLY POSSIBLE- THAT
COMMITMENT KEEP TRYING TO
AUTOMATE THAT PROCESS I THINK
IS REALLY COMMENDABLE AND I
WOULD URGE. LIKE MY COLLEAGUES
WHO SPOKE PREVIOUSLY ABOUT URGE
YOU TO. EXPLORE ADDITIONAL
OPTIONS FOR ADDING STIMULUS OUT
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE KNOWN TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND YOU ARE
CONNECTED TO OTHER BENEFITS
PROGRAMS. AND IF YOU TAKE
EFFORTS TO BREAK DOWN SILOS
BETWEEN. BENEFIT PROGRAMS AND
TAX CREDITS. RESEARCH LAST WEEK
FOR THE CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB
SHOWED. HOW MANY PEOPLE. WILL
BENEFIT PROGRAM NOT GET FEDERAL
THE LEAST ANYTHING WE CAN SAY
THAT'S PROBABLY VERY MUCH TRUE
FOR STATE RELIGION WELL. I
REALLY REALLY COMMITTEE FOR
THIS MOVEMENT FORWARD AND WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO EXPLORE
FURTHER OPTIONS THANK YOU. SO
MUCH BY THANK YOU. YEAH LINE
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE BURKE
BEHALF CAL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO AB EIGHTY
FOUR THAT WOULD IMPOSE
SIGNIFICANT BURDENS ON THE
BUSINESSES IN THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY THAT IS NOTED HAVE
ALREADY BEEN SEVERELY IMPACTED
BY THE PANDEMIC WELL WE AGREED
THAT- EMPLOYEES WERE LAID OFF
FOR NO OTHER REASON THAN THE
SHUT DOWNSHOULD BE REHIRED
IT'S COMMONSENSE AN EMPLOYERS
WERE OLD WILL ALREADY DO SO AS
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE ALREADY
TRAINED TO TEN MILLION WITH THE
EMPLOYER PROCESSES. HOWEVER
THIS BILL MICROMANAGES HOW AN
EMPLOYER REHIRED EMPLOYEES
SETTING UNREASONABLE PERIOD
OFFER EMPLOYEES EMPLOYMENT AND
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS THAT WILL
ACTUALLY SLOW DOWN THE HIRING
PROCESS AT AS WE HAVE HEARD
FROM EMPLOYERS THAT ARE ALREADY
OPERATING UNDER LOCAL
ORDINANCES AND WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THAT HE BEFORE THE
DENTAL FROM LITIGATION UNDER
THE LABOR CODE PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT WE ARE
STILL CONCERNED WITH THE
MANDATE THAT THE LUNCH OF-
IMPOSES IN THE CHALLENGES
EMPLOYERS WILL FACE WITH
ENFORCEMENT THE DISCUSSION THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER REPRESENTATIVE
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT. THE
COMMISSIONER HAS DISCRETION TO
ASSESS PENALTIES DOES NOT SEEM
TO BE BORN OUT IN THE LANGUAGE
AT THE LANGUAGE THAT STATE THAT
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER SHALL
ASSESS CIVIL PENALTIES AGAINST
AN EMPLOYER IN VIOLATION OF ANY
OF THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CONTENT THE INTENDED TO PROVIDE
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER WITH
DISCRETION WE THINK THE
LANGUAGE NEEDS TO BE WORKED ON
ONE OTHER THING I WANTED TO
KNOW THAT HASN'T BEEN DISCUSSED
IS THAT THE BILL WILL NOT SEND
SAID INTEL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
WHICH WE ARE QUESTIONING WHY-
THERE'DBE A THREE YEAR.
REQUIREMENT FOR THIS BILL TO BE
IN PLACE SINCE WE HAVE ALL
DISCUSSED- THAT THE ECONOMY IS
THAT AND- GONNA OPEN UP IN JUNE
FIFTEENTH INFO AT QUESTIONABLE
AS TO WHY THIS WOULD BE NEEDED
FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS. FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FIND.
SIXTEEN YEAH LINE SIXTEEN YES
SIR HI THIS IS SIR CHRISTOPHER
CIRCULAR TO WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOMEOWNERS
COMMUNITIES- AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY EIGHTY
FOUR. THANK YOU. FINE LINE.
TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS A LARGE GAIN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION- WE ARE
IN A SPECIAL OPPOSITION TO A
LOT OF NUMBER TWO A. B. EIGHTY
FOUR. THANK YOU. FINE. THIRTY
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
ERIN EVAN REPRESENTING THE TREE
CARE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION I'M
CALLING REGARDING AB SEVENTY
NINE. IMMEDIATE ACTION TO
PREVENT WILDFIRES THIS YEAR I'M
INCLUDING SEVERAL OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS AND THAT PACKAGE
LIKE THE FIRE PREVENTION GRANT.
HILL BREAKS AND COMMUNITY AND
HOME HARDENING ALLOCATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. PINE THIRTY
FOUR. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS CAN LIMITS ARE
PREVENTING CHILDREN NOW
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY NINE PARTICULARLY
AROUND THE SUPPORT DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES SUPPORT OUR
CHILDREN AND- AFTER CARE TO
STAND. ON BUT PARTICULARLY THE
PARITY BEING OFFERED OUR CHILD
CARE BRIDGE PROVIDERS AND THAT
WOULD. MAKE THAT AND PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BY. TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RENEE BY
ART OR WHAT YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT F.
AB EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE THIRTY SEVEN. SH GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO A BE A NEED FOR. IT WILL
APPLY TO RESTAURANTS ON THE
PROPERTY ACTED BY THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY FIVE. PARDON ME WE MAY
HAVE HAD AN ISSUE WITH ONE
THIRTY FIVE WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO ONE THIRTY TWO. A GOOD
MORNING CHAIR NUMBERS STEVEN
MYERS SPEAKING ON THE WILDFIRE
UNFORTUNATELY BE SEVENTY NINE.
AND A HALF FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION
PARTICULARLY SUPPORT THE
FUNDING FOR STATE PARKS. FOR
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION THE
FUNDING FOR THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY. AND FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL ONSERVATION CORPS. WE
SUPPORT THE ENTIRE PLAN AND ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN THE BUDGET.
THANK YOU. THE LINE. THIRTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING NATALIE MAX
ON BEHALF OF THE TEMPLE REGION
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT OF THE
RECKLESSLY DEMENTIA FAN COULD
COUNTY I WANTED BECAUSE THE
POOR AT EIGHTY SEVENTY NINE THE
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE AND THE
GREEN SUPPORT OF EARLY ACTION
FROM WILDFIRE ACTIVITY COMING
OUT OF. THE STOCK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR. BYE. NINE GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DEVELOP GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WHICH
CHARLIE PARKER THE EARLY ACTION
APPROPRIATIONS FOR WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE CONTAINED IN AB
SEVENTY NINE FIVE SB EIGHTY
FIVE. ANY PROJECTS CRITICAL TO
ADDRESSING THE THREAT OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE THAT CAN
BE DONE NOW. ARE THE PRIMARY
REASON FOR DOING IT AT THE
TIGHTENING THE SOONER WE CAN
ALLOCATE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- FUNDING THE MORE
LIKELY THESE PROJECTS CAN BE
COMPLETED IN ADVANCE OF THE
UPCOMING FIRE SEASON WE
APPRECIATE THE- OKAY FINE
FUNDING FOR FORESTRY SECTOR
ECONOMIC STIMULUS. INCLUDING
THE CLIMATE CATALYST FUND AND
FUNDING THAT PRESCRIBED FIRE IN
PORT HEALTH PROJECT WHICH CAN
BE IMPLEMENTED IMMEDIATELY TO
REDUCE THE IMPACT OF WILDFIRES.
INCLUDING REDUCING IMPACT BOOK
ON OUR COMMUNITIES- WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THESE ISSUES AND
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YEAH I'M SURE ONE MOMENT PLACE.
AND AGAIN LATER GERMAN FOR YOUR
COMMENT IF YOU HAVE NOT
COMMENTED AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE TWENTY
FOUR. AND THEN AFTER CAN YOU
TELL ME HOW MANY ARE REMAINING.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAITLIN
VEGA ON BEHALF OF UNITE HERE
LOCAL ELEVEN AND THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY LABOR FEDERATION
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT AT AB
EIGHTY FOUR. EIGHT PANDEMIC HAS
BEEN DEVASTATING FOR
HOSPITALITY WORKERS OUR LOCAL
HAS HAD CLOSE 295%
UNEMPLOYMENT- AT VARIOUS TIMES
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC. STILL
VERY SIMPLE IN ASKING HOTELS AS
THEY RE OPEN TO BRING BACK THE
SAME WORKERS WHO WERE DOING THE
JOB THE FOR THE PANDEMIC HEAD.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO PARTNERING
WITH THE HOTEL INDUSTRY ON WAYS
TO BE BUILT IN THE OPEN- BUT IT
ALL STARTS WITH THE PEOPLE WHO
DO THE WORK THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT AND WE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR MEMBER FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS. ISSUE
THANKS VERY MUCH. BUT I'M SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THAT
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU MODERATOR. ALL RIGHT
SO WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON OUR FIRST BILL AB
SEVENTY NINE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR DOLLY- HELLO MR
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS ALEXANDER HI
SKINNER I. SENATOR NELSON HI.
CABALLERO I THANK THE START
NIELSEN AYE CABALLERO I.
CORTESE HI PORTES THE HIGH.
DALAI. HI SORRY I RAZA I RAZA
HI EGGMAN HI EGGMAN I GROW.
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER HI. LAYER
BY LAYER HI MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ
CAN IN FIVE MEN I NEWMAN. THE
TROUBLE HI FILLABLE I IN HI CAN
I STERN WORKOUTS SKI. WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN I BELIEVE
THAT IT HAS A BY TWELVE VOTES
THERE CORRECT. SO DOES BUT WE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THOSE MEMBERS WHO MAY. RETURN
SO AND- AND- I WILL YOU'RE
ACTUALLY MISTER CONSULTANTS ARE
REFERRED TO MR STEPPING CHAU
DOES MISTER SEPARATE JOBS. NOW
FOR NEXT BILL IS AB. EIGHTY
FOUR FOUR AS FOR THE MOTION ANY.
FURTHER DISCUSSION SOME OF.
THAT WAS THAT YOU SENATOR DOT
COM LONGER HE SAID SO MOVE NO
BILLS ARE YOU SENATOR SENATOR
COMELEC YOUR SIDE. HAS MOVED.
AND- MISTER STEPPING CHAU YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON AB
EIGHTY FOUR AB EIGHTY FOUR
MOTION TO PASS SENATORS SKINNER
HI SKINNER HI NIELSEN HELLO
NIELSEN NO. CABALLERO HI
EVERYONE HI FOR DAISY HI OKAY
THE AYE DOLLY NO NOT REALLY NO
TORONTO I WOULD RATHER HI. HI
EGGMAN I GROW KAMLAGER MARGARET
FIVE LAYERED HI. PLAYER HI
MCGUIRE MULLIN THIS. MAN. FIVE
MILLION HI NEWMAN THE TROUBLE
NO THE TROUBLE NO HAN HI THEN I
STERN BY CAL SKI. HI WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN NEVER RIGHT
NOW IS NINE TWO THREE BUT WE
ALL THE ROLE OPEN FOR THOSE
MEMBERS THAT ARE MISSING THE
FINAL BILL IS AB TWO ONE THREE
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS CLEAN
UP IS THERE ANY COMMONER
DISCUSSION BEFORE WE I
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. MOVED RIGHT
DOCTOR PAN IS MOVED IT. FIVE
MISTER SEVEN SHARP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB TWO THIRTEEN THE
MOTION TO PASS THE SENATORS
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI. NIELSEN
I'M NOT VOTING NIELSEN NOT
VOTING CABALLERO HI CABALLERO
HI FOR DAISY BY PORTES ET HI
DOLLY. THE RAZA HI THE RAZA HI
EGGMAN HI EGGMAN HI BRO.
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER HI LAYER
BY LAYER I MCGUIRE MELENDEZ IN.
FIVE MILLION HI NEWMAN THE
CHIRLA BOTH HI FILLABLE I PAN
HI CAN I. STERN WHY COUNTY. THE
BILL HAS TURNED VOTES BUT WE
WILL HOLD THAT ROLE OPEN. AND-
FIVE MAYBE SERGEANTS COULD LET
THOSE FOLKS. KNOW THAT AREN'T
ON THE FLOOR THAT THEY COULD
COME BACK SO THAT WE CAN.
REOPEN THE ROLE AND- FINALIZE
THESE BILLS. AND WHILE I WAIT
FOR MEMBERS TO RETURN I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR. BY
PARTICIPATING IN THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO EITHER OR HERE
OR CALL DAN FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. AND OF COURSE IF
ANYONE. FIVE DID NOT CALL IN ON
TIME OR WANTED TO COMMENT MORE
OR WAS NOT ABLE TO TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE AND YOU CAN NOW GET
OUR DETAILS ON OUR WEBSITE
SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN ARTIFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS.
OKAY.
UHHUH UHHUH.
YEAH.
YEAH YEAH.
WHAT OTHER
MEMBERS ARE WE WAITING FOR.
UHHUH AND
- OKAY SO I WONDER I
CAN SUPPOSE IF YOU CAN JUST
REQUIRED. ALL RIGHT WILL REOPEN
FOR MISTER MCGUIRE TO ADD ON TO
OUR BILLS BUT WE STILL HAVE
SOME MEMBERS WHO ARE ON.
PRESENTING COMMITTEE SO I WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO BUT FOR RIGHT NOW
ALL OPEN IT SO MISTER REQUIRED
DOESN'T HAVE TO STAY. IN THE-
IN OUR HEARING ROOM. SO MR
SEVEN CHART CAN YOU REOPEN THE
ROLE ON THE FIRST BILL AB
SEVENTY NINE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR.
AB SEVEN NINE MOTION TO PASS.
SENATORS GROVE MCGUIRE HI BUYER
AYE MELENDEZ NEWMAN STERN Y.
CASKEY. SORRY WE TRIED WE'VE
ADDED- MISTER REQUIRE ON BUT WE
WILL KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN THOUGH
BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME OTHER
FOLKS SO LET'S- NOW OPEN THE
ROLE ON AB. I. EIGHTY FOUR THE
RE HIRING AND RETENTION BILL.
AB EIGHTY FOUR MOTION TO PASS
SENATORS GROWTHMCGUIRE AYE BAR
AYE MELENDEZ. NEWMAN STERN BY
CASTING. ALRIGHT SILVA HAD ONE
SENATOR OUT ON BUT AGAIN WE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN ON
THAT BILL AB EIGHTY FOUR
BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE'S THREE
SENATORS WHO ARE STORE GOING TO
RETURN SO LET'S OPEN THE ROLE
NOW FOR AB TWO ONE THREE. THAT
IS THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
CLEANER. AB TWO ONE THREE
MOTION TO PASS SENATORS. GROWTH
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
NEWMAN STERN PLUCK OUT. RIGHT
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER REQUIRE
WE WILL STILL LEAVE AB TWENTY
TWO ONE THREE OPEN ADDICT. WHAT
UNTIL THE THOSE MEMBERS WHO ARE
PRESENTING ANOTHER COMMITTEES
ARE ABLE TO JOIN US SO I WILL
JUST- HANG OUT.
MR WHITE
BECAUSE HE WILL LET YOU VOTE
FOR NICE. WE WILL RE OPEN THE
ROLE EVEN THOUGH E HAVE TO
OPEN IT AGAIN BUT THAT'S RIGHT
THANK YOU FOR COMING BACK TO
COMMITTEES. WE WILL- MR STOP
AND SHOP LET US REOPEN THE ROLE
ON AB SEVENTY NINE WHICH WAS
THE FIRST BILL WE HEARD BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR. AND LET'S- GO
AHEAD OPEN THAT RULE. AB SEVEN
NINE MOTIONS TO PASS SENATORS
GROWTH MELENDEZ. NEWMAN STERN
WHAT COUNTY HI MY CASKEY I.
RIGHT THANK YOU MR AKOWSKI FOR
ADDING ON TO THAT BUT WE ARE
HOLDING IT OPEN BECAUSE WE HAVE
A FEW OTHER SENATORS WHO WILL
RETURN SO WE WILL NOW MISTER
STEPPING CHAU OPEN THE ROLE FOR
AB EIGHTY FOUR WHICH IS THE RE
HIRING RETENTION OF DISPLACED
WORKERS AB EIGHTY FOUR MOTIONS
TO PASS SENATORS GROWTH.
MELENDEZ NEWMAN STERN WHAT
KASKY HI MY CASKEY I. ALL
RIGHT- NOW- IT WILL KEEP THAT
ROLE THE ALREADY FOR ALSO OPEN
WE'RE NOT CLOSING THE ROLE. AND
WE WILL MISTER SEVEN SHOP OPEN
THE ROLE ON AB TWO ONE THREE.
AB TWO ONE THREE MOTIONS TO
PASS SENATORS GROW GROW
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NEWMAN STERN
Y. CASKEY HI MICHALSKI. ALL
RIGHT AB TWENTY TWO ONE THREE
WILL ALSO STAY OPEN UNTIL
MISTER SENATOR STERN AND
SENATORS- NEWMAN ARE ABLE TO
RETURN FROM COMMITTEE. YES
BILLS THAT WOULD BE.
FOR ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE ONE OF OUR
SENATORS SENATOR NEWMAN BACK SO
WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE AGAIN WE
STILL HAVE THE ROLE OPEN BUT WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
FIRST BILL AB SEVENTY NINE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR SO SENATOR
NEWMAN CAN OUT ON GO AHEAD MR
STOP AND SHOP AB SEVENTY NINE
MOTION TO PASS SENATORS. GROW
MELENDEZ. NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN I STERN. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN. BY HIS MR
STERN CENTER STERN COULD STILL
RETURN AND WE WILL NOW GO TO AB
EIGHTY FOUR WHICH IS THREE
HIRING AND RETENTION OF
DISPLACED WORKERS MISTER
STEPPING CHARCOAL THE ROLE. AB
EIGHTY FOUR MOTIONS DO PASSED
SENATORS GROWTH MELENDEZ NEWMAN
NEWMAN AYE STERN. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL STILL HOLD THAT OPEN AND
WE WILL NOW GO TO AB TWO ONE
THREE THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
CLEAN UP MR STOP AND SHOP. AB
TWO ONE THREE MOTION TO PASS.
CENTERS GROW MELENDEZ NEWMAN
AYE NEWMAN HIGH STERN.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN NOW WE ONLY HAVE ONE
MEMBER WHO STILL NEEDS TO
RETURN BUT WE WILL KEEP ALL
THOSE BILLS OPEN ROLE OPEN
RATHER SO THAT SENATOR STERN
CAN OUT ON.
SO MAY APPLY A- B.
YEAH- LAST FOUR YEARS YEAH WHAT.
YEAH THE. W. NO I WANT TO
THINGS ABOUT THAT BUT SHE EVEN
EVEN MORE IF THEIR. AND I DID
ASK JOINT WHICH ALREADY HAVE
SHE CAN AT LEAST PROVIDE A LIST
OF WHAT IS CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED.
WE'LL GET BACK BUT THE NUMBER
BACK WITH THEIR. TO- ANOTHER
WAS CHRIS DID RESEARCH FOR ON.
FRANCIS ON THE- YOUR QUESTION
ON THE SLIDE SEVENTEEN FIRST.
WELL IT ON- THE COURTS MODERN
STUFF.
ALL RIGHT US SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE HAS ITS LAST
NUMBER BACK SO WE CAN NOW- HAVE
ROLL CALL ON THE THREE BILLS
THAT WE HEARD AND IT WITH THIS
WEEKEND I'LL BE ABLE TO CLOSE
THEIR ALSO BUT LET'S FIRST
START. WITH AB SEVENTY NINE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR MISTER STUFF
AND SHOW YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB SEVEN NINE MOTIONS TO
PASS SENATORS GIRLS MELENDEZ
STERN. HI STERN AYE. THREE WE
WILL NOT BE- THE OTHER TWO
MEMBERS WILL NOT BE COMING TO
COMMITTEE SO WITH THAT- MISTER
STEP IN TRACKING YOU TELL ME
HOW IT WHAT WAS THE FINAL ROLL
CALL ON THAT BILL AB SEVENTY
NINE. SIXTEEN HIS ZERO NO VOTES
ALL RIGHT AB SEVENTY NINE IS
PASSED SIXTEEN OZ ZERO NO AND
THAT- THE BILL IS. LET'S SEE
THAT BILLS OUT ALL RIGHT NOW WE
WILL- DURRELL CALL ON AB EIGHTY
FOUR THREE HIRING AND RETENTION
OF DISPLACED WORKERS MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THAT ROLE
AB EIGHTY FOUR MOTIONS TO PASS
SENATORS GROWTH MELENDEZ STERN.
HI STERN HI AND MR STEPPING
CHAU YOU GIVE ME THE WHAT THE
FINAL VOTE ON THAT BILL IS. HIS
THIRTEEN NOES THREE. RIGHT AB
EIGHTY FOUR IS OUT HIS THIRTEEN
NOES THREE NOW WE WILL GO TO AB
TWO ONE THREE THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS CLEAN UP MISTER
STEPPING CHARCOAL THE ROLE. AB
TWO ONE THREE THE MOTION TO
PASS SENATORS GROVE MELENDEZ
STERN HI STERN I. GREAT MISTER
SEVEN SHOW YOU GIVE ME THE
FINAL VOTE ON THAT. I FOURTEEN
NO ZERO. A THIRD FINAL VOTE ON
AB TWO ONE THREE IS- ICE
FOURTEEN KNOWS ZERO. AND WITH
THAT- THAT BILL IS OUT. BEYOND
THE. COMMITTEE THE SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE HEARING IS NOW
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.